Do I look to you?
Look fantastic.
You look great.
Beautiful.
All right.
Feel better.
All downhill from here.
Got Joe to think I'm pretty,
you're alive.
Hey,
what's up?
How are you?
I'm good.
I'm,
I'm insecure.
I'm very insecure.
I'm very,
I want you to like me,
but you know already like,
you know,
you're going to read.
You're very hard to read.
Shut up.
Yes.
When you're sober,
you're hard to read.
When I'm sober,
wanting to get high,
when I'm high,
I'm hard to read.
No sober me to read.
Or at least you just like people more.
I was like,
everybody,
here's the thing about you that you don't know about with our relationship.
When I easy,
when I know you did just arch your back there for us,
like different.
Um,
when I started doing standup,
you were like this very mythical,
um,
hero at the comedy store.
I came into the comedy store when you and Carlos had your big,
uh,
saga.
Oh,
so you had just like your exodus,
you're very ceremonious or unceremonious rather exodus when the comedy store was
happening.
So I never really met you,
but you were like this deity at the comedy store.
Oh,
well then no.
Do you want to weigh in on that?
You were there and going there for,
so I never really knew you.
Like I feel like so many other comedians that I admire,
I at least have had some facetime with and you,
I only sort of started knowing and last year we met,
met at the laugh factory.
True.
But I'd seen you a bunch of times and I'd like to,
yeah.
But we had no vibe.
We never told me have since then.
That's true.
But I'm just saying because I have nine years of you being this sort of very
elusive,
you know,
big foot like I never quite knew if you really existed.
It's weird when people have perceptions of you outside of you and yellow then.
Yep.
It's weird when you meet someone perception then when you're like,
oh,
I like them.
I didn't think I did.
Yeah,
that happens.
Well,
I think a lot of it is it becomes a Rorschach test,
right?
If it comes like my projections onto you and my insecurities,
like if I see you and you don't give me what I need to feel secure,
I'm like,
he hates,
he doesn't like me.
I'm just didn't.
I had a friend,
a friend tell me something about a celebrity that they met and they were like,
yeah,
I'm at all.
And when I said a hard one,
but he's a fucking Dick,
you know,
you didn't even talk back to me.
I'll go,
okay.
Yeah.
You just said hi to them.
That's it.
And all sudden he's a dick.
Oh,
you anything.
Yeah.
It's like you have this idea of what someone is and then based on a limited
interaction,
you create a narrative.
You know?
I know that when people,
um,
this is going to sound like,
if I can do person bloviating about people that recognize them,
but when someone does get to use that word,
it's a good word.
I've never used that in my life.
It's a good word because it does fit.
Sometimes I ramble and I want you to reign me in if I start getting boring or
being redundant.
And bloviating,
but when someone comes up to,
uh,
like at the airport and he's like,
Hi Whitney.
Like I instantly,
sometimes I have to say that I'm like,
I just feel like I cannot give you what you need right now.
Like,
what you need from me.
I can't give you,
like,
I can take a picture with you,
but I can't,
there's no way you're going to walk away from this exchange feeling good about
this.
She was this,
she was this,
you know,
I get very insecure that I can't deliver what someone needs from a person.
They know where the guy,
I'll never forget this because I didn't know this guy at all.
And uh,
it was after show,
you know,
I say hi to people,
the whole thing.
Take pictures.
And then he goes,
hey man,
I'm dating this girl and she's about to have a baby.
Um,
what do you think I should do?
Like what?
I go,
I don't,
what am I supposed to tell you?
Have you seen the movie,
the staircase?
A staircase,
You haven't seen the staircase.
The documentary is that when he throws her downstairs,
two women are found at the bottom of the staircase.
It's actually,
it's what people think the jinx is.
It's was a Sundance channel documentary.
It was like 12 part documentary series.
It's phenomenal.
You'll love it.
Really 12 yes,
12 parts.
I don't want to give away too much if you guys have seen it.
Um,
uh,
tweet Joe of what your thoughts are on it and let's all convince him to dedicate
12 hours of his life.
Because I am fascinated.
Speaking of Warshak test,
I'm fascinated whether you think he's guilty or not because usually it is all,
um,
whether someone thinks it's guilty or not says more about them than it does
about the case really.
Because again,
we projected her 12 parts.
It's a lot of,
I know,
that's what I said.
I made the mistake of only downloading one at a time.
I watched six and my first sitting,
it's that addictive half hour,
hour,
hour.
I promise you,
I will bet you you have a lot more money than me,
so maybe we shouldn't do this.
Um,
I will bet you any amount of money that you'll watch it in two days.
That's not going to happen.
It made me want to quit writing because I was like,
I will never be able to write something that's compelling is this true life
thing.
Wow.
Phenomenal.
The staircase.
Why wouldn't you just be inspired to write because you want to quit.
That's the fundamental difference between me and you just reared its ugly head.
I'm a quitter and you are not.
You're not a quitter.
That's what,
that's not true,
but you're a hustler.
I'm a hus.
Yes.
People say that a lot and I never know.
I never know if it's an insult at all and in my estimation are mine.
The way I'm defining it is you,
you're always working.
You know,
when we think maybe the difference between the similarity between me and you,
I grew up playing sports and you learn,
I think a lot of comedians don't.
You learned the harder you work,
the better you get and you get that sort of mentality that like,
you know what sport?
I played basketball really seriously,
blah,
sprinting,
a lot of running around and just like the,
yeah,
I,
you know,
this acid is pretty new.
Actually.
I didn't have,
I seen you didn't,
you didn't know me six years ago when I was like anorexic,
anorexic.
Yeah.
I use,
I don't want to be clinically throw that term around,
but I was like,
um,
I was like a hundred pounds.
I was when I was doing the show with Pr.
You're ready Chris on NBC.
I was like UB zero.
Yeah.
And I had a lot of eating disorders in college,
which is why I had to stop playing sports.
Really?
Yeah.
Eating disorders made you stop playing sports.
I had to choose.
So I was really serious.
Basketball,
played Aau.
I played in Europe,
like super psycho about it.
And then I started modeling just for money,
not really fancy modeling,
don't believe Wikipedia.
Um,
and uh,
I was sort of starving myself for modeling and starving yourself and playing
basketball for hours a day.
I don't go well together,
so I had to sort of give up basketball.
Wow.
So you went with that over food?
Yes.
Why did you do that?
Well,
modeling was paying my bills.
It was the way I was raised was,
um,
you know,
your appearance was very valued.
My mom,
I now realize as an adult in retrospect,
had an eating disorder and being thin was very valued in our home.
The messages I heard where my mom,
who was very,
you know,
skinny was I have to lose five pounds.
I still don't lose that fat at any one time.
Some will compliment her.
She'd be like,
no,
I'm at,
I'm so fat right now.
Like,
those are just,
that's how I was.
We don't realize the impact that those messages have on kids.
Something that we just think it's a flippant comment.
I need to lose five pounds for me.
Like I was like,
oh,
she's a size zero,
but she still needs to lose five pounds.
That's what women are supposed to look like and how they're supposed to,
you know,
that just morphea was ingrained in me very young.
Um,
and there was a sort of culture of perfectionism.
Uh,
uh,
where I grew up in my household because I had,
was not,
um,
I was neglected quite a bit and it's a natural sort of reaction for kids to have
perfectionism as a result of that.
So yeah,
because you think,
you know,
you can't,
the children can't understand that their parents have flaws because it would be,
you know,
just too traumatic to their psyche.
So we think parents are perfect.
If I'm not getting attention,
that must be,
something's wrong with me,
so I need to work harder,
be prettier or thinner,
a more successful,
achieve more,
which I think is where a lot of my achievements stuff to try to get your parents
to pay attention to,
or a kid that's when it started is if I'm just perfect,
I'll get this attention from these people who weren't capable of giving it to
me.
And then it sorta started manifesting in other ways.
Uh,
as an adult,
I think I had a very similar thing.
Yeah.
It was definitely neglected as a child,
but I think that I sought it out from other people,
not necessarily frame.
Yeah.
Well,
that's what I,
you know,
and,
and similarly,
which is I think why I had,
and I'm in Alanon so I'm,
I'm in recovery for this,
but people pleasing Alanon is like,
um,
if you had any kind of alcoholism in your home growing up,
which is not necessarily like I did have an alcoholic parent and I have a,
a drug addict sibling,
but alcoholism,
um,
you know,
for alcoholism to be present,
alcohol doesn't necessarily need to be present.
So it could still be signified by,
um,
compulsive behavior.
Workaholism a codependent relationship and addictive relationship among your
parents,
uh,
gambling,
sex,
food,
all that sort of stuff.
Anything that's a down on stand for Allen on his,
um,
that's actually a really good question.
I do ACA,
which is adult child of alcoholics.
Alanon is more for like if you're married to an alcoholic,
if you have a kid who's an alcoholic,
like because addiction is a family disease and it affects everybody.
So I am,
I know it's such a fucking pain in the ass in that regard.
It's a very sort of pernicious disease because sometimes good word pernicious is
a good one because it's,
um,
we're live,
I've got to pull out all the stops and we can't fix this in post.
Um,
is that,
uh,
it sometimes alcoholism affects the people not drinking the most.
So I wasn't drinking,
growing up,
but I,
uh,
because of here's another one,
how insidious alcoholism is.
I was acting like an alcoholic.
I just wasn't drinking.
So I was like arrogant and developed an ego of like,
I'm the angel in the house.
Everyone else is an asshole.
I'm awesome.
But I was still manipulating,
lying,
managing,
controlling,
you know,
and codependence alcoholics are addicted to alcohol.
Codependence are addicted to alcoholics.
So I,
as a result,
I'm dating alcoholics.
I'm dating guys who are literate,
people who need to get rescued.
A saved you dated guys who were illiterate.
I dated one guy who couldn't read,
couldn't really smell,
kind of lots of,
um,
lots of auto correcting.
Uh,
yeah.
Hey,
are you a basketball later?
What?
Um,
so,
uh,
yes,
I did.
I did go through that.
I did a lot of like alcoholics,
needy people,
troubled people who'd always date girls that were really,
really fucked up.
Just
stag.
Fiona Apple.
Well that's the best one ever day.
Oh,
but I did same thing.
Bam.
He calls him vampires.
Oh,
he had some bad ones,
but so it's recreating your childhood circumstances.
So I was the caretaker as a child.
Right.
You know,
I would put my mom too bad.
I would cook dinner.
I was always the one fixing things and trying to stop fights because I was,
you know,
based on my mom basically told me I was like a mistake.
I was born,
no one planned me.
And when he told you that?
Yeah.
Jesus.
It wasn't good.
It wasn't the,
the um,
our shine,
our shining moment as a family.
When I don't send money,
I get reminded money to your mom.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
It's dark fairy malls.
Chris Rock said in the hallway,
the comedy store one night,
I think you were actually probably there.
Uh,
he said,
um,
when you give money to people,
it's only a matter of time before they start hating you,
because then they start resenting you for supporting them and sort of robbing
them of their own dignity.
And then if you have any kind of boundaries there,
all of a sudden like,
oh,
we'll just,
because you give me money,
you think you can talk to me that way.
And it's like,
well,
no,
I'm just like,
you have self respect.
It's it,
it seems to me that the people that need money always need money.
Like you,
you,
when you give the money,
it's not really helping them.
It's enabling.
Yeah.
I mean there's some people that just need money.
I mean,
I've had friends who just needed money.
Yes.
Someone wrong transmission broke.
Fuck.
You know,
that's one thing.
But this,
the people that always need money.
Yeah.
They just,
you can't fix that hole.
That hole is just,
they'd come back to,
oh,
it turns out we were late with the payment and now there's interest in this and
that.
And so do you think that,
okay.
And then there's,
we just had an issue with Bubba Bubba and like,
Oh fucking Christ,
this doesn't end.
Does it?
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
and it's interesting.
I've had to work really hard on the parameters of when I can give money,
when I can't,
my system now is basically to only pay bills directly cause that way.
I know you do this all the time.
So this is an all the time thing.
I am cash burner Gel.
They being hemorrhaged hemorrhaging money through my family.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
because I didn't grow up in an environment.
No one had health insurance.
No one went to the doctor.
So now,
you know,
both my parents had strokes.
Nursing facilities are crate and no insurance,
like the whole deal.
So it's been,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
you talked about me working hard.
I worked hard initially because I needed,
you know,
I didn't have a choice,
I didn't have money and now I still have to work hard to sort of pay for all
these other things,
which I think maybe in some ways keeping me,
you know,
I'm motivated because I'm never going to get ahead.
I'm never going to be,
you're very aware of the solvent.
You might be like kind of frantic and all over the place and motivated and you
know,
you give all this frantic a little bit,
but in a good way.
How so powerful.
You've got like a lot of really?
Yeah.
I feel like that's off.
It's an armor.
I'm a,
it is,
it's not like a negative thing,
but it's like,
wow,
that girl is getting shit done.
You know,
when I say frantic,
maybe that's not the word.
Maybe the word is,
um,
pretty kinetic.
Yes.
Fabulous.
There's a lot of good ones,
but you know,
you're,
you're not stagnant.
You know,
you're,
you're constantly in motion.
Well that is a,
uh,
yes.
I define it.
You texted,
sorry to interrupt with what you texted me.
Like,
here's a perfect example though.
I'm doing a documentary on head trauma.
What,
what the fuck?
I mean,
I know she's touring,
you're in the middle of doing an HBO special.
You've always got some shit going on.
Your,
you've always got these projects.
Then you're like,
I'm directing a documentary on head trauma.
I'm like,
what?
What was violence?
Violence.
You wanted to talk about violence and just like,
Whoa,
what does this fucking chick is crazy.
I,
um,
yes,
I am a,
I mean it is a literal disease.
I do have workoholism which means you define yourself through productivity.
And that's how we,
my self esteem is derived essentially through what I'm able to make.
So as you're so aware of all this,
well yeah,
I'm in pretty hardcore a recovery for it.
So you know,
I am an Alanon.
I do EMDR.
I'm in trauma therapy,
so I'm addicted to therapy.
I,
you know,
what,
I wish,
I wish that I could actually find a healthy addiction.
I've found a lucrative addiction work as I was somewhat of a lucrative
addiction,
but um,
I'm definitely addicted to waking up and being conscious and self aware.
You know,
like that's something that appeals to me and I wasn't in my twenties but again,
like we were just talking about someone earlier being being a mess isn't cute in
your thirties and forties being asleep and unconscious and just being a
disaster.
It's just not cute anymore.
There's something about lazy people in their twenties that I find adorable.
Yeah.
But when I see a lazy can you turn 30 cute,
41 of 46 year old lazy guy.
Nope.
You didn't do that yet.
No.
I got to get to it.
What?
And also as a girl,
I mean this is,
I mean guys have the stigma too,
but as a girl like you can be crazy and you're 20 minutes,
you can't be crazy in your thirties it's not sexy.
That's not true at all.
Really.
Yeah.
Long as you don't show up at someone's house and break windows.
Those days are over.
Those days are really fast.
You know?
It's like what kind of crazy?
My kids aren't big enough to behave like that and get away with it.
Unfortunately.
That's not really,
like,
that doesn't really help.
Yeah.
You can get away with,
you can either get away with her.
You can't like tits.
Don't ever that,
never that tipping point.
Really.
I don't think so.
I just feel like I'm,
as a woman,
you're already,
anything you do.
People want to call you crazy.
And,
uh,
even if you just talk sanely at a little too high,
but decibel level,
um,
and people are so quick to call us crazy anyway that I don't want to actually be
crazy.
That's interesting because guys will never have to worry about that.
They don't have to worry about the idea that you're too ambitious or that you're
too forceful if you don't like it.
No.
But for a man,
a man,
no,
no.
That guy before,
he's decisive.
He's an Alpha.
He's got his shit together.
It's a turn on.
And then for a girl to be like that,
it's like she's crazy.
She mega bitch,
pms psycho.
She's a psycho.
She's stalking me.
It's like,
no,
I just,
I like you.
Yeah.
Or like I need to make plans because I have to schedule my flight.
Are we hanging out or not?
She still stalking me like,
okay,
am I stalking?
You know,
you think that that's a power move though,
that people do that to try to like make you feel unsecure saying something like
you're stalking them or saying,
you know,
like when people act like that now,
I don't overthink it as much now.
To me it's just more um,
uh,
signifies
unintelligence like when someone in a fight with me,
if we're together and you say crazy psycho or bitch,
I just lose respect for you because I'm like,
I know you have a bigger vocabulary than that.
And if you're leaning on these sort of like pop terms and these vague terms that
get us nowhere,
like I'm just gonna lose respect for you.
Well,
those words,
unless someone really is crazy and if they are crazy,
we'll stop hanging out with them.
It's like calling someone stupid.
It's not,
it's not productive.
It's not helpful like sometimes called stupid.
It's very productive.
It is actually,
you know what?
Some good words,
idiot is pretty good if you don't overuse it.
Dumb,
dumb,
dumb me.
I love dummy.
I Love Dominique and dumped up dummy because it's so belittling.
I'm not even going to call you stupid dumb.
It's really less silly.
Goose is pretty good.
He's silly.
Silly.
Goose is like,
you can kind of get away with it,
which just silly goes.
Yeah.
You can't really like get mad at someone for calling you a silly goose.
You know what the worst insult?
Like if you,
if you want to hurt the person you're with,
what do you say it's going to hurt them?
I don't know.
What do I know that I,
uh,
the most hurt I've been is when a guy said to me in a fight,
not bitch,
are we allowed to curse?
I'm sorry.
I think we already have,
I don't know these days,
bitch.
I don't fucking know.
Uh,
who's ever told you we can't hardly getting sued?
I don't know.
I'm just,
it's,
it's an instinctive,
I have PTSD microphones and sang [inaudible] it's just,
I'm sweating.
I'm already sweating.
None of those words hurt me.
They actually just make me lose respect for you and you personally,
Joe,
what?
I'm pissed at.
These,
they're like clam shells.
I grab grab,
I am like fly trap.
Um,
and is,
uh,
I,
I mean our relationship was going to be over anyway,
but we were arguing about something and he goes,
you know what,
Whitney,
you're a lot,
a lot.
You're a lot that bothers you that you know,
it was number one.
You don't even respect me enough to be specific with your insults.
You're going to be vague.
And it just meant like all of you is too much.
Like you're just too many opinions,
too many things to say.
You're too loud.
It was just like be less of what you are.
And that weirdly hurt me more than anything.
That's so strange.
You're a lot.
If someone,
somebody have said that to me,
I'd be like,
yeah,
bitch.
Yeah.
But it tapped into an insecurity that I already have,
that I'm too much for men,
that they,
that I have too much,
too many ideas,
too many opinions.
I'm to Alpha.
Oh,
we're getting deep here.
Too much for men guys to guys are not super onboard with girls like having
opinions and,
and appointments and you know,
that sort of thing I've noticed.
Really.
Yeah,
like opinions and appointments for the last year.
I've hit my car from guys that I've dated.
Why have you hit your car?
What kind of car you got?
Well,
I had a g,
I have a Tesla now,
but I had a g wagon and I used to park it at the guy's house.
I was dating a,
they'd be like,
can I walk to your car?
I'd be like,
I ubered I would Uber like two blocks back to my g wagon.
Shuck and drive home.
Why would you do like weird the mountain emasculate them?
Cause you have a nice car.
Dayton broke dude.
I know,
I know Oregon that Seth Macfarlane hit me up.
Um,
I don't know cause I was like,
I don't,
I would never like not date a guy cause he didn't have money.
I don't see my,
you know,
I don't think of,
but I guess I did uh,
gravitate towards God.
I work,
guys gravitate towards me.
Who,
um,
were intimidated by sort of my alpha.
They're gravitating towards you though.
Yes,
there are those guys.
He'd get taken care of by women and it's very strange.
Call me,
I'll make you don't want this guy.
But there's this guy that I know,
he's an actor and he's gone from one older wealthy woman to another older
wealthy woman,
divorced,
wealthy woman to another divorce.
Who is a habit too is you're looking for it.
But what he does,
he,
he gets these girls to pay his bills cause he's trying to act.
He's trying to be an MRI.
That's so not sexy though.
Oh,
it's pathetic.
I've done both.
He's got a ponytail in sold.
I would pay for that high,
um,
suede boots.
Sometimes I want to kill him.
You can't do that when you're broke.
You can do that when you're a rich black man.
You can't do that when you're a broke.
Like I can't even do that if you're white.
If you're rich,
you can do that.
If you're Farell,
you can't Richard Branson wear knee highs swayed.
But no,
it's completely naked moccasins.
The guy with the stitching on the bottom around the actions.
You,
would you be attracted to a girl who had more money than you who earned it,
who didn't get it bequeath to her?
I have a theory that guys like girls who inherit money,
but they don't like girls who earn their own money.
Wow.
More money than you.
I don't think they would bother me.
Why don't I have a money problem?
You don't,
but,
but because money represents resources and on a primal,
primordial level,
she's the alpha.
What does it mean me?
I'm not worried about money.
You know what I mean?
So that once you have it,
yeah,
I've got plenty.
Yeah.
So it's not like
when you have enough money,
this is the way I've always said,
everything good comes free.
Yes.
You know,
like do you want to buy a car?
We'll go get a car.
Yeah.
Like things become free.
And when things become free than money stops being an issue.
When money's really an issue is when you don't have it.
When you don't have it,
someone else has like,
fuck,
I wish I had it right.
How do I get it?
I'll give you some going to kill me,
so I'm just going to give me sure.
What about the money going to give me sense,
symbolic and it's still going to money.
She'll come in my womb,
you know?
Right.
It gets this weird fucking,
you get this weird relationship and it starts to represent more than just paying
for a cup of coffee.
It's,
am I a man?
Am I a woman?
But I do feel like I have become,
this is gonna sound so sexist.
Uh,
I feel like me making or being whatever this thing that has happened where I'm
able to pay my bills,
I'm doing,
I'm miming a weird thing and judge,
um,
funnel
and what movie is,
this isn't going away going indeed it's true guys,
or it has changed a guys' relationship to me.
I've noticed that ever since I started making money.
Guys sexually want to dominate me,
choke me,
spit on me.
Oh,
I've gotten spit on.
Uh,
that did happen in my twenties when I was broke though I was 20s in Britain and
my brain broke.
Guys wanted to coddle me and contact and grab your face.
And where did it,
now that I have money,
I'm getting choked.
I mean,
spanked.
I gotta I gotta I gotta tell me what this is.
I had a guy put his four fingers in my mouth and just leave him there for like
two minutes.
Um,
what's that?
I don't know.
Wash your hands.
You have a seven year old.
She's sick because she touches things and then touches her mouth.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you just learn so much about you.
You could never be saying,
oh,
by the way,
today you better make this marriage work forever because you're not going to be
able to handle it because the hands in the mouth,
it's very unsanitary out there,
Joe.
Oh,
hands on.
Well,
I'm not worried about myself,
so he stuck his hand in my mouth and it was,
I've,
I've spent every night at the comedy store for 10 years.
My immune system is on point.
I know I've got to shake about a thousand hands and night
sharing a microphone with 3,300 road comics every night.
Does a number on your immune system.
I've never been sick and never gets it.
Yeah,
she didn't hold those hands.
Does it?
Or just
sharing a microphone with Jay London.
You're good for a while.
Um,
he's like pig pen.
Everyone's googling j London and no results found on last comic standing.
So he stuck his hand in my mouth and I was like,
this did not happen in my twenties.
And I,
and I'm thinking,
am I,
or we gagging me,
whatever,
I've lost the plot at this point.
Did you ask them right?
Well,
I'm sitting there and I'm like,
just waiting for something that happened.
I can't wait.
Um,
and so I'm sitting there and I'm like,
and then for a minute I was like,
maybe he lost his balance and he just had,
and he just
like had to commit to it because it'd be too hard to be like,
sorry.
And then I was like,
maybe he was worried I was going to speak,
or
maybe he just wanted to stop me from talking.
I don't know what it was,
but this did not happen in my twenties when I was broke.
Well,
spit on in the face.
Spit in the face was a bit in the dark.
Yes.
No,
actually wealthy.
Yes.
Hmm.
Maybe more wealthy than you.
Maybe.
Here's the thing.
Here's the thing about my,
my,
uh,
this nebulous wealth that I have.
Everyone thinks I have way more than I have and it's been in the press that I
have all this money.
So I think guys that do have more money than me think I have more money than
that,
which I sort of,
I see.
So maybe it was,
he,
he thought I had more than I,
so you want to spit on you?
Yeah,
he wanted to go.
Just so you know,
bitch with the Tesla,
you think you're so cute with your TV shows.
I'm about to fucking just treat you like a Thai hooker.
There are people that like that though.
That's where it gets weird.
And if you date someone who likes weird shit,
yes.
And then you go to someone else.
I've had that recently where I dated,
I was in a relationship that was relatively sexually perverse and then dated
someone who was very not.
And I was like way overshot the mark.
I mean,
am I this?
I'm just fuck it.
Um,
I am going to be single forever after this bike goes.
I did have a guy whatnot.
Cause here's what you do now.
I need more coffee from Jesus Christ.
When you see this is too graphic,
um,
I feel like I'm covering a lot of this stuff so that Neil degrasse Tyson and
covered on this podcast,
are we being,
are we just talking about the moon landing?
Um,
you have to gag on Dick's now.
No you don't.
Yeah.
Well if you don't,
you will be exercised.
Yes,
you will be.
Your head will be pushed down.
Um,
yeah guys push your head down and you're like,
oh shit.
Okay this is happening.
I'm like,
I have a fucking,
I have a Tesla two blocks away.
Why are you jamming my head on it?
And then so I just thought that's how you did it.
And then I dated this guy,
uh,
and I did that and he goes,
oh no,
no,
no
bear's name.
He goes,
he goes,
oh,
I'm actually not turned on by girls hurting themselves.
And I was like,
Oh God,
I was so embarrassed.
And I was like,
okay,
I'm till I'm off the grid.
I've been off the grid.
Now I'm back.
Uh,
and I just don't know what's normal anymore.
Like I don't even know.
That's fascinating.
It's was,
it's fascinating to be a woman who's got a lot of money.
He's got a lot of power in that,
but in that pretty well you got plenty.
All right.
We don't have to go over to number hopeless.
I'm not a damsel in distress.
I don't need to be rescued,
which a lot of guys want to rescue girls.
I think if you make more than $34,000 you were in the 1% of the world.
Wow.
So you're in the 1% of America.
So that's it.
You got a lot of money.
So most men are dating girls that are like waitresses or bartenders.
All the costumes you dress up to play role play by the way.
Oh really?
We're interested is in bartending.
Yeah,
it's it.
That is when I really realized like,
oh my gosh,
guys love us to be in like subservient positions cause like roleplay.
Well,
no,
I'm just saying it's very telling that the only sexy costumes available or like
candy striper,
secretary.
Well,
that's a good point.
There's cop,
nurse nurses not subservient.
They're kind of taking care of,
it's not doctor true.
There's no doctor.
There's no CEO.
There's no,
yeah,
but there's always been a fighter.
There is the fantasy of like the boss who calls into the office.
It makes you eat her pussy.
That standpoint,
that's,
there's a lot
that's now I'm,
that's encouraging.
Yeah,
but it's always like the guy has to dominate the boss,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
it's always,
she's like,
where's that paper?
And he's like this paper to Dick in your mouth.
It's always like that.
It's never like,
she's like,
you're fired.
And then he just leaves in Jarvis off.
You know?
That's a weird dynamic though.
The one I'm in now that you're,
you're making me think about it.
I never dated a girl who made a lot of money,
never dated a girl who made more money than me.
That's for sure.
I'm thinking about it.
Never.
I don't think so.
Maybe when I was like really broke.
I think that like I'm recently divorced,
guys are into it.
Oh right.
Cause they don't have to pay.
They just had to pay,
give half of their shit away.
So I feel like they're a little more receptive to,
so I literally was saying to friends of mine,
like,
Hey,
set me up with,
you're recently divorced friends.
They'll be into it.
But don't you think that there's like this a broad dynamic,
right?
There's a lot.
There's a lot of different kinds of people.
I used to have to find someone who's into a strong woman,
but not like a Beta man.
That's the thing.
Like someone who's more alpha than me.
You don't want like a male feminist who's like catering to you,
who's like a Beta,
who wants to take care of the kids who doesn't want to work and stay home and an
equal.
I lose respect for people very quickly.
And so it needs to be your competitive,
it's what it is.
You're a predator.
That's true.
Not a Predator in a bad way,
but you have predatory instincts.
You see weaknesses pretty quickly.
I do,
yeah.
And once I see it,
I can't unsee it.
That's why that guy freaked you out when he said you're a lot,
because I'll tell you a lot,
but I'd say it's a good thing.
Like you're a lot.
He hit all my insecurity of I'm not feminine and like I just want like in a
relationship.
I don't want to be the alpha.
I want to be like the subservient obsequious Asian girl.
Quite frankly,
I don't want to have to be the boss in my relationship.
I want this to turn into some weird sort of dating advice.
Well,
you stop letting me talk to the dog.
It's so good for disaster.
Fascinating.
People are excited about this right now.
It's dudes at their pants off all around the world.
Thank God.
Hit me up.
I'll pay you
just,
you don't want to pay their bills.
It'll get ugly,
ugly.
I'll pay the,
I won't pay the ostensible bill.
I'll pay the valet.
You pay the,
I'll pay the half of the house in the vacations you cover the valet.
Oh,
how about that?
That sounds like a good dude.
I don't want anyone to think I'm pink because I did date a guy that did not have
money and I would wire him money and so that he could pay him.
When we basically said that when we went out to dinner,
he could pay.
Whoa.
So that people didn't think I was paying.
Yeah,
that was a mistake.
I'm not going to do that again.
That was like a week ago.
That was
Hashtag [inaudible]
bizarre.
Well,
I would imagine it's probably very hard.
I mean,
you're saying it's very hard,
but I would imagine that
it's hard anyway.
I,
you know,
again,
it's,
you know,
I'm not like,
I need to get married tomorrow and did a Ba da Da da,
you know,
so I'm not,
um,
but it's all,
you know,
it's good comedian.
The good news about it being a comedian is you're like,
I got to use it all I could to alchemize this and sublimated this pain and to
jokes.
Yeah.
I just try to use it.
Well,
you've been doing that a lot on stage talking about this kind of stuff on stage.
Oh yeah.
Yes I did in my last session.
I was like,
Huh?
I have not.
I have not done standup,
and since I shot my special,
I try to take it back.
I tried to take like three months off after every special because I feel like
number one,
I don't like doing old material because I feel like a half,
like I just feel like gross.
And then number two,
I feel like I start doing a bad impression of myself if I do it,
if I don't take a break and rewire my brain.
Right.
Okay.
That's interesting.
Reboot Stan hope blocks to do that.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Stan hope takes back chunks of time off.
Yeah,
he's detoxing probably.
He's got aids right now.
He just told me as aids.
She told me
that's not true.
No.
Oh,
she,
I was like,
you should fucking Charlie Sheen.
I'm coming.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
That was good enough.
Sucks.
So he's really,
yeah.
Yeah.
Very gone.
Do you have him?
No.
Very drunk of him.
Oh,
God killed his dick with booze.
Is that something you can,
they can bounce back your concern.
He's on my hit list,
but he's literally my tie.
Hi.
He's the perfect guy for me.
I know you have to talk to you thinking problem needs money.
Cam doesn't need money.
He makes a lot of money.
Yeah,
I guess that's true.
It doesn't have a big overhead.
Doesn't even live in New Mexico.
Arizona.
Bisbee Arizona.
He owns like a shock.
He's got the most bizarre house.
Pull up an image of Doug's Tan hope's house cause he puts it up online.
Not only as he put it up online,
he tells you where he lives.
He knows no one's going to rob them.
Oh they do?
They could.
Problem does nothing there go,
go rob.
When he goes to do steal one was wacky suits.
Do you get someone straight store?
He doesn't.
He doesn't pop off vodka.
He's got like a laptop.
He'll,
you know,
he's still,
that'll go get another one.
I saw a comedy joke books,
comedy star.
He had that like plastic gallon of pop hall.
Vod.
There's this house.
This is a,
this is a party that he puts on.
I fucking love him cause he's the real deal.
He's like a real American original.
He has a house in Bisbee,
Arizona.
He gives out the address online and people come to his house for a Superbowl
party.
Regular people,
he doesn't anybody,
anybody.
They drive.
People have flown in from other countries and driven the Bisbee Arizona to come
to Doug,
Stan hope's house and they come into his living room and hang out with them.
He's got a girlfriend Bingo.
Who's doing the shit out of her fucking mind.
Crazy like medicated sees things that aren't there like suicidal or I heard them
on stern I think could be,
you know,
I don't know if she's suicidal.
She's hilarious.
He's still having,
he still has a relationship and I don't,
yeah,
all of the on sex relationship.
I guess it's just not sexual because he can't fuck or because doesn't,
it doesn't have any desire to.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
You know,
I think if you just drank all the time and don't take care of your body,
just that Surratt.
Yup.
Well I think most of you go into survival mode.
I'm sure his body's just trying to keep him alive.
I don't have time to fuck right now.
I don't know.
Maybe we shouldn't procreate.
That's just stop this.
It could be that it's cigarettes to cigarettes definitely.
And Kill your sex drive.
How old is he?
He's my age.
He's 48 but you look like you're like Benjamin Button.
You're like aging backwards.
Well I work out a lot.
He doesn't,
but he makes fun of me.
He's like,
how many surgeries have had,
I'm like,
I've had a bunch surgeries,
cracking joints and all that kind of stuff.
It was ripping them.
Are you worried about your body from um,
martial arts?
I used to be worried.
Yeah,
but everybody dies.
Everybody dies.
Yeah.
I mean I worry about some things when things aren't going so well.
What happens when you don't work out?
Get this fixed your shoulder?
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying like when things go wrong,
I started going,
oh this,
this one might not be good.
What's going on here?
This is clicking shit.
Don't get an Mri and might break things up.
But I've had so many things fixed,
you know.
Do you think that surgery is now improved?
Cause I heard that the RG three surgeries on his knee and it wasn't as that the
quarterback for the Redskins who's a RG three know football.
Oh literally don't even know the rules.
God love that.
I don't know anything really.
Yeah.
The only thing Chris,
sexier than a guide knowing everything is the guy knowing nothing.
I just left.
I don't know anything.
Like I had a friend of mine invite me over to a Superbowl party and I thank God
I had a fucking excuse,
but he,
look,
he just
wasn't a super bowl party I guess.
Super Bowl's in February.
It was a football party on Monday night football party.
Only reason I know it's because the um,
a guy that owns it was explaining to me that the,
um,
the knee surgeries made his knees better than they were before the injury.
My knee's would definitely better than they were before.
My surgeries can now improve your,
well,
I've had ACL reconstruction on both my knees and the way they do it now.
Why have one that did the older way,
which is a Patella tendon graft,
who they take a big slice of your patella tendon and then they open you up like
a fish and then they drill it into the knee,
the uh,
the Tibia and the fibula.
And um,
that one's definitely stronger than a regular ACL.
And then my other one I had replaced with a cadaver ACL,
which is even stronger because it's,
um,
they use a achilles tendon,
which is much larger.
Oh,
wow.
And it's,
uh,
that one is much less invasive to like the recovery time was incredibly quick.
Like I was a,
I went to a party five days afterwards.
No cane,
no nothin.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
Just walk around,
pimp,
pimp lamp,
just walked around.
I didn't even have a limp.
Wow.
I mean w I didn't have full flex Asian,
like I couldn't bend it all the way,
but Aquino get enough where it looked normal.
Like I just walk in my shoulder
and I should have gotten surgery.
Surgery would have like dramatic,
like the way he would've done it would've made it better.
I just didn't want to get surgery.
Wow.
Long goes us.
Ah,
two years.
I just had,
um,
four,
four months ago I had stem cell shots in my shoulder.
Yeah.
That was going to go Vegas.
Oh.
I was going to,
um,
get soldier shoulder surgery cause I had a labor room tear and a rotator cuff
tear and there's some bro.
I apparently I've dislocated my shoulder before and Jujitsu didn't know it.
I didn't know.
But that's,
Jujitsu is fucking so brutal.
Yeah.
When you're,
you know,
engaging in sport for 20 years and the whole purpose of the sport is trying to
break bodies,
things go wrong,
you know.
And um,
I guess my shoulder got dislocated and pop back in place and I didn't know
broken shit in there.
Yeah.
And then I heard it again from practicing archery and from lifting too much
weight.
So I just literally pulled some of the tendon off the bone,
literally pulled it off myself.
Like I didn't,
I didn't do it.
Nope.
It wasn't like someone yanked on it or I fell,
I just kept pulling my shoulder gets sore.
I'm like,
shut up pussy.
Oh yeah.
See that.
And you've got,
see I have that inner monologue of if it hurts,
you're doing something right.
That's how I grew up.
You know,
if you're in pain,
like you'd think shit hurt.
And so I never athletic thing though.
Yeah.
I never say uncle,
but you can get,
if your shoulders still fucked up,
you get these uh,
stem cell shots.
Now the around,
I'm sorry,
I got the plasma where they spin out the white blood cells.
Is it that one?
No,
definitely platelet rich plasma.
Prp.
Yeah.
And that's really good that that helps.
Healing reduces inflammation.
And there's a more advanced version of that,
which is called Regena keen,
which I had a series of those done in my shoulder and which helped a lot,
but it was more of a temporary fix.
It would help.
It would reduce the inflammation,
it would help the pain.
But then slowly but surely,
cause I kept working out,
the pain would,
you know,
sort of reemerged,
but the stem cell shots were a fucking complete game changer.
Wow.
And people always ask,
how much does it cost?
It costs,
it costs $2,500,
which is a lot of money.
I know,
but the fucking result,
one shot,
I mean my shoulders.
Fantastic.
Now I worked out today.
No problems,
no pain.
Yeah.
I mean I did chin-ups a,
I did rose and all these different things.
It doesn't bother me at all.
Like,
nope,
no pain.
I was like that close to surgery.
I was like,
I just can't keep doing this.
Like it used to make all these clicks.
It makes way less clicks now.
I used to have to wear that shirt
that the,
the good,
the shirt
that has velcro on the back that pulls your shoulders down.
It's like I'd have to wear it like 30 minutes to wait.
The one that,
who's that basketball player?
Uh,
that,
where is it?
Yeah,
the tall,
tall black guy.
Does that narrow it down?
Um,
it's a whatever.
It's a shirt that it's probably a compression shirt but has velcro on the top of
the bottom and they adjust it so that it changes the way that you walk and
stuff.
Cause there's,
well,
there's just amazing new innovations in science and medicine.
Like the,
what they're able to do.
There's this guy,
I think his name's Peter Willing,
the guy who invented Regena king,
uh,
who's in Germany,
Dusseldorf,
Germany,
and he has fucking Germans always,
well they don't have the same restrictions that we had for the longest time.
The fucking,
the entire Bush administration fucked science and medicine in this country where
they couldn't do stem cell research.
And then they finally figured out how to do all tall autonomous stem cell.
I'll Tom Wallace.
Wow.
Are you saying I'll Google that tall Agus autologous,
uh,
three fat.
They take stem cell through your own fat or through your bone marrow.
They drill a hole in your hip.
They suck marrow out,
make stem cells out of that,
but they don't even have to do that anymore.
Now they use placenta from a woman who has a sincerity and section.
Yeah.
They take that placenta,
make stem cells out of that.
And that's what I got on my face.
Did you do?
You put that text placenta and claustrum claustrum and spit apparently
lot of weird fluids on my face.
Well,
this guy,
this doctor is,
they are literally months away from releasing this new procedure that they have
that reinvigorates Collagen in your skin,
like changes your body's production of Collagen.
They have some sort of an injection and through that injection your body
reproduces college and like it did when you were 20 wow.
Yeah.
People's faces just couldn't go.
Right.
Those are just going to go away.
They're like,
this is fucking complete.
Total game changer.
Wow.
When is that coming out?
Well,
they're setting up the infrastructure when now just to deal with the amount of
patients,
the overwhelming amount of patients that are going on debt.
As soon as this happens,
there's going to be like a trillion dollar business once it launches.
Let me ask you a question.
Would you as a man do it?
Fuck yeah.
Why not?
Yeah,
why not?
Good.
Why not?
I'm glad to know.
I mean,
I don't think I could get my fucking face.
I wouldn't get my nose fixed.
I don't think I would get my lips done.
I had my nose fixed the inside of it.
Oh,
got it.
Like a,
the cartilage and all this shit.
But it actually made my nose wider in some way cause I think they showed these
wedges in your face.
You don't want to smell it.
No,
I don't want us to have you broken in a ton of times.
I don't even know how many times.
Oh yeah.
Steven go to get it fixed.
Broken.
And once I did,
but I didn't get it fixed until I was 39 or something like that.
38,
39 maybe when I got it done.
But it was amazing.
Oh God.
It was the craziest thing.
I broke it for the first time when I was five.
I fell down a flight of stairs when I was five.
He smashed my is like,
well I was a latchkey kid.
Opened the door,
get outside,
you know?
Yes.
And uh,
I fell down a flight of stairs,
smash my nose.
And it's been crooked ever since.
But the inside of it was all fucked up.
And then from a lifetime of martial arts,
kickboxing,
it's just been hit so many times.
It was always bleeding.
There's always something in there.
So yeah,
when you were nosebleeds,
you've seen cauliflower ear.
Cauliflower ear is from the break in the ear.
When the tissue breaks away,
uh,
it fills up with blood and that blood calcifies that also happens in your nose.
So the inside of my nose was sealed with hard calcified blood that had just,
it had just spins smash so many times that I couldn't breathe.
Like I had no breathing out of my nose.
Like this one was like my left nostril,
right nostril was just walking
down the wall is not good for an athlete's terrible.
Yeah.
Especially for kickboxing.
So I always had my mouth open.
Yeah.
And you have three race or a mouth guard.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it's hard to breathe and if you open your mouth and you can hit with your jaw
open,
you get fucked up.
So it was never good,
but I didn't get it fixed for the longest time.
But once I did get it fixed,
it was amazing.
It was like,
I know
you're like,
is this how everybody just lives all the time?
They shove these,
these big fucking things up my nose.
He's big like foam tubes and stretched it out and he cut it.
There's things called turbinates in their big trim,
the turbinates.
So they literally changed the shape of the inside of my nose and shove these
things up my nose like a little wider.
Um,
uh,
I get really bad migraines.
And when we were brainstorming,
like trying to figure out what it was like playing like whack a mole with how to
eliminate certain variables,
they did cortisone in my sinuses and that made me breathe so much better.
Quarter cortisone in my sinus.
So you had some sort of inflammation.
A lot of us have like sinus inflammation we just don't know about.
And it wasn't like much less nasal.
And I sounded less like Fran Drescher,
which
people like that though.
Don't know.
That sounds so like five minutes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's no surgery.
Whatever.
No surgery.
Yeah.
So,
but if your shoulders still fucks with you,
you should really think about all women have,
we hold a lot of our emotion here and in our shoulders and necks and purses.
So my surgeon was like,
you cannot carry of 30 pound purse with all your shit and what you need.
What is fanny fanny man
get you really?
Can I get a uh,
Joe Rogan Manny back please?
When you're new shipment,
contact them.
Get a ship.
Yeah,
because women we carry,
I was carrying a purse on my broken shoulder.
Oh really?
Fuck me up and I do it.
Why won't you carry on your other shoulder?
Because I mean it's just like,
even when this was,
I did six months of physical therapy on this right.
One,
which is as I'm sure you've gone through is so fucking boring.
You just sit there and have to rock it back and forth and like hold you,
get to a place to do it.
Yeah.
Colon.
Hello.
Yeah,
I did it right once
and then I went home and I got these band.
I'm like,
you're just resizes my come just do it at home.
It's crazy.
It's so annoying.
And then I had to,
um,
because of,
you know more about this than anyone,
if I heard this thing,
it affects the left and then it affects my hips and then cause it's all
connected.
So I started sort of having to do my whole body and written in that.
That's when I got an ass.
[inaudible] Yep.
That happens.
A lot of people not getting an ass,
but you're like,
you hurt your knee and then because of your knee,
you'll get all the gold paint left hip problem because it's all about the badge.
Right.
And I am hyper mobile,
hypermobile,
which means I lift and Ron and everything with my bones and not my muscles.
So I had to relearn how to like,
fuck this up man.
Very like western European inbred bullshit sort of thing.
I also have,
um,
uh,
Osgood slaughter is in my knees.
What does,
which just means you're,
you get like a bone spurt and your bones grow too fast.
So I have like this,
oh hollow,
it's a tumor.
It's just like a box.
It's like a ball of nerves and aliens,
just gee it probably GMOs plus like a,
I would imagine.
Plus like you know,
a western European Mutt,
alcoholism gene.
And so the bones get like,
does it hurt or do you just,
I had like a just grew too fast.
Real,
you know,
that happened to my massive,
huge with dogs,
especially purebred dogs.
They were sick.
Like he was getting,
getting some like limping issues and it was when he was a puppy and they were
saying that his,
he has too much protein is food.
You have to buy him blow large dog food.
And I'm like,
what?
Like real large breed.
Cause I was feeding him like raw eggs.
Yeah.
It really healthy stuff.
And his,
uh,
his body was growing too fast.
Wow.
He's getting like you would have like a limp and I thought,
oh,
it might have hurt himself.
So I brought him in because I've had dogs that had ACL surgery.
I had,
um,
yeah,
they have notorious,
I have a pit and a great Dane puppy who I'm going to the same thing with.
He's just growing stuff.
I had this female pit that had a rear legs done.
She had one rear leg,
like Halston shed this weird limp when she was walking around with one foot off
the ground.
So I brought her in.
They had a fix that they do it by changing the angle of the bone.
They cut the bone so the bone like it doesn't,
you know,
like instead of it like falling backwards,
they cut it at an angle so that it doesn't do that.
Interesting.
It's weird how they do it.
They don't do it like a person where they replaced the ligament.
They change the shape of the bone.
Can I just say something random?
I'm so glad.
I mean,
I'm sure we'll look back in 20 years and there'll be so much new technology and
we're like,
I can't believe we live in a day where we didn't have the,
the,
the stem cell injectors at our home or whatever.
But like,
my dad got sick with my animals getting sick.
I'm like,
thank God we don't live in the fucking 20s when they were guessing,
they were just guessing like they worked out all the kinks.
Yes.
Did you ever see that movie I'm with in order to Caprio uh,
where he played the aviator?
He was,
he was there with his parents,
Howard Hughes.
His parents were telling him like listen to the doctor you need to smoke
cigarettes cause it would make you more vigorous.
Oh Geez.
Let's say they used to tell people that is milk is good for you is it's supposed
to be.
Um,
definitely not good for explaining that because of the amount of it actually
strips your bounds of vitamin D in some way.
I don't know.
I'm not an expert but we might look back when I'd be like milk isn't as good for
you as we thought.
Here's the deal with milk.
This is a big part of what's wrong with milk,
homogenization and pasteurization.
So when you're drinking milk you're drinking milk with no enzymes in it cause
it's all boiled down here on the shelf for a year.
Yeah.
Even cooked overcooking vegetables.
You're not really getting that,
you know,
and some vegetable ordering a salad at a restaurant could be the most unhealthy
thing cause it has so much fertilizers and chemicals and stuff on it.
That's a big one because Wa water that's running off from the fields,
from pastures where cows are shitting and that can,
that can be a real issue.
Women get over 50% of their calories from salad dressing.
What I brought that
challenged
Jesus Christ,
I
always eat salads and they think they're eating so healthy and they're just
eating like salad crew tones.
The GARP,
trans fats,
the almost sometimes the worst thing you can get the grocery store is just an
apple because of all the shit in it and chemicals on it and the dyes and the
know what I like on Salad.
I like oil,
olive oil and vinegar,
but good luck trying to find that shit at a restaurant.
Yeah,
it's hard to get oil and vinegar.
Most restaurants do.
I want to give you a ball.
Sorry,
age.
It's true.
Garbage.
Garbage be that guy that shows up with the dressing and it's flat.
It's not good.
That guy is not my vagina will dry up and can you imagine,
would have a guy shows up with his own wine
at a restaurant alone.
Okay.
Drink it out of a flask like an adult.
How would you feel if you went to a date with a guy and you went to a fancy
restaurant and he pulled out?
He had a bag with him,
like a velvet pulled out,
pulled out
a Sutter home.
You got to bring your own wine and it's like a white one.
You should really go die.
I have a good one.
I went out with a guy who was an actor,
said that that's how you start mocking.
You want to be an actor.
What a great idea.
There's none of those and flood the market.
It was more of an actress actually.
He had long hair and he likes sort of economy and to going out to dinner with
them and it's the guy that was dating my,
my friends.
The older ladies,
the same guy with the knee high.
I don't know who that guy is,
but possibly actually works quite a bit.
And we went out and comfortably a foot and a half shorter than me or less feels
like it.
And he was wearing his hair down.
When the food came,
he put his hair up,
oh Christ.
And then when they took the plate away,
he took it back down and he's going to die.
I mean,
I literally was like,
I can't,
I don't,
what do I do?
Is that why we should own guns?
As I was like,
I now feel like we all need it all at a handgun.
I need to hang up.
And he did when he was talking about like a trip to like Italy or something.
And when he taught he'd be like,
you know,
and then the police said to me are saying,
but GE,
Ge,
which means take a left there and that.
So he would talk in Italian and then translate it for me.
It was such a bummer.
He's trying to let you know that he's bilingual.
Yeah,
I don't like it when guys hurt themselves.
You don't need to.
Oh Man.
It's on a turn on my mouth is numb.
I've had a lot of really,
cause I haven't just stom sort of single goalie and like I also went on a date
with a guy who at the end of the day,
um,
put his hand up and said,
all right dude.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a rough one.
That was rough.
I thought I had been shot.
I felt like I had been shot.
All right dude.
It was actually like a,
what's this?
What's this thing when you're,
it's like a springing back.
Yeah.
Going forward.
Roll a ball and you're gonna go for it.
That's what I got.
I was like,
that's when I realized like,
Oh,
I'm now gender neutral.
I don't even,
I think,
I think what you've nailed it already is that there's a lot of guys that are
intimidated by the fact you're successful and ambitious.
And I think that's a,
that's a legit concern.
You know,
I was,
I was listening to this Ted talk a Ted radio hour rather than,
have you heard about the salad dressing?
It was one of the recent ones.
Um,
I forget what the name of the title was,
but um,
uh,
disruptive leadership,
that was the one where the woman was talking about the word bossy and about how
women are told to not be bossy.
Like if a man does it,
he's assertive.
But if a woman does it,
it's the first time that ever heard that,
that I thought,
Ooh,
maybe there's something to that.
But then you never,
I've never,
no one's ever gonna say,
Joe Rogan's Bossy.
Well,
don't,
I don't,
no one wants to be called bossy.
Not going to say like,
he's like a survey.
But if say I was Bossy,
I'd be like,
okay,
well maybe I'm doing something wrong.
You know,
like a lot of times people get carried away or get caught up in there the
momentum of their own behavior and don't even realize how they're acting.
Someone has to tell you,
hey,
you're being bossy.
And you know,
oh,
but they don't say that about guys.
Like they can say the guys,
he's a dick or he's overbearing or whatever,
but a woman becomes bossy.
But then she was going on about it.
We should encourage men to not work and take the role of child rearing and let
the women work.
And I was like,
okay,
this bitch is crazy.
It's like this whole men and women.
It's like,
it was personal.
I think it was,
I think it was her own trip that she was like trying to like make it more normal
for men to do that,
to be the one who takes care of the children and we should encourage this and I
don't think you should encourage it one way or the other.
You know,
I think there's going to be a bunch of people that liked that.
This,
I know a guy who's of a mom,
his,
his wife works all the time.
She's like a high powered executive,
but she's fucking miserable.
She works all the time.
And the,
the,
the husband's always like,
let's go on vacation.
And I'm like,
she makes a ton of money.
He doesn't make Jack Shit.
Yeah.
He's a very bright guy too.
He's a professor,
but he like teaches like one class rides his bike everywhere.
He's a fucking total hippie and she's fucking winding.
Yeah.
Every day.
And they make tons of money,
but it's not on him.
It's a weird dynamic one.
Whenever we're all together,
I'm like,
what?
This fucking relationship is so odd.
I mean,
it's interesting.
I was talking to this,
um,
neuro anthropologist hollow hollow.
He,
um,
you would like him actually.
So I'm in this project that I'm doing has a lot of like sort of experts in it,
like project,
it's a pilot for HBO where I have instead of like a,
you know,
a friend who's like the exposition friend who's like,
you know what you should do,
you should get a makeover.
I instead have,
um,
you know,
people,
Ted talk people and you know,
Malcolm Gladwell and Michael Morin ner anthropologists and neurologists come in
and sort of explain what's happening because I think a lot of us sort of our
pretending,
uh,
or are misinformed thinking that we have choices and all of the decisions we
make when so much of it is our primal reptilian brain just running the show and
human nature taking over.
And we like feminism.
Like,
of course I'm pro feminism,
but human nature and evolution of neurology doesn't catch up as fast as social
progress does.
You know?
So a lot of this is against some level of human nature.
So I was asking him if he thought humans,
we're inherently a matriarch.
You're patriarchy.
And what animals are a patriarchy in which our matriarchy,
so like lions are pretty much major article in terms of they sort of do all the
work and the male lions sleep 22 hours a day.
Right.
Sort of.
But the male lines are much larger in the male lions protect the pride.
Yes.
The real matriarchal societies.
Hyenas.
Hyenas,
yeah.
Yeah.
And Bonobo apes,
the females have faked dicks.
No.
Yes,
they have a pho penis.
They have an actual penis and they give birth out of it.
It's an enormous penis.
And they mount the male.
So the only mammals,
females are larger than the males.
Well,
and it's because life is a heinous,
so ruthless that male hyenas were regularly eat the babies.
So to keep them from eating the babies,
the woman or the gangster be bigger.
Yeah.
A bigger and stronger.
And they've dominate the men and fuck them,
they fucked them with their giant fake dicks.
Um,
uh,
that's the happiest I've ever seen.
You,
by the way,
explaining that and glean a real problem with wildlife.
I fucking love it.
Love
it.
But it's also what,
what does patriarchal mean and what does matriarchal me,
maybe it does it mean physically bigger?
Does it mean the ones,
so you know,
the female lions doing the hunting,
the male lion is pretty much the boss.
They,
you know,
call the shots in are like bigger,
but they have to sleep most of the time to preserve their energy and it's not
economical for the them to be up and running around.
Um,
Bonobo Apes,
the women sort of call the shots in terms of who kills who and who's in charge
and they're sort of like,
have the resources and stuff.
And because there are a guy knock cracy,
is that what it's called?
They use their vagina's too.
You know,
like if someone's pissed off,
they fuck up.
Yes.
A Guy,
Nah.
Ocracy interest.
So they use sex to sort of placate and to get what they want.
And I want it for yes,
essentially.
Exactly.
And so is that,
you know,
and in humans we would say that's a weakness and that's,
you're being
fucking standard.
You're using what you have to make it as me.
Um,
so we were talking about that and he sort of was making a strong argument that
humans could have a inherent matriarchal traits that we,
um,
you know,
oh,
press.
Yeah.
Just in terms of like,
you know,
if,
what does power mean?
And you know,
men are sort of designed to do the hunting and the killing and the protecting
and were sort of designed to do all the organizing and all of the like real shit
work.
But we're not sort of allowed to do that a lot in this society.
So it's just
primal organizing,
raising the kids,
making decisions about allowed to,
you don't think so?
Well,
I don't know.
I mean,
it's,
I think that we're,
um,
uh,
criticized a lot when we do what we do best at,
you know,
we're called crazy and neurotic and obsessive and she's obsessed with getting
married and nesting in the house.
And she wants to change the carpet.
It's like that's what we're wired very much.
Didn't do the way men,
the reason why men will criticize that,
it's because they don't understand those instincts like mine,
my wife takes care of everything.
She's,
she's the one who's like responsible for all the,
like if you go to my house you'd be like,
Oh,
this is even your fucking house.
Some chicks house.
Like I have a few rooms in my house that her mine.
Yeah,
clearly.
Yeah.
But most of the houses,
my wife's designed and all her shit and she just let her,
but I,
I'm my market because I don't understand it.
I'll make fun of it.
But it's,
and I think what I should mention is I think that women are shamed for that more
than men shaming women.
I think that there's this thing now where if you're like great at organizing the
house and cooking and cleaning,
like you're not a feminist.
It's like,
well
I hate that word.
I don't like the word feminist.
So loaded.
It's so loaded.
And it's not that I don't like the quality,
I just don't like,
there's so many hashtag feminists,
there's so many people that there's people that I,
I'm obsessed with.
I go to their Twitter page.
Do you,
cause every fucking post they make is about gender.
It's like the,
most of their identity is based on feminism.
There's a giant chunk of what they do and they think they're being activists.
But you're not
a lot of feminists are a lot of feminism doesn't mean being equal.
It means women should be superior.
It's like,
wait a second.
I thought the goal was that we were supposed to be superior at,
which means that we should equally be judged and criticized and all these other
things that it can't be like,
I'm going to speak out,
but you're not allowed to attack me or question anything.
I said,
you're a right.
If you question anything I say,
it's like,
no.
Um,
so I think that is a very tricky place and I'm,
I'm working on this thing that's sort of about how our primal neurology,
like what annoys you about your wife today?
Not You,
particularly Joe or whatever it was.
I know.
Again,
I wouldn't noise you about your boyfriend today is what kept you alive 2000
years ago.
So I essentially all the things that are not your girl going through your cell
phone today,
2000 years ago was her surveying land for tigers and threats.
You know,
today it just manifests in going through your cell phone.
Are Your threats to the chest?
Yeah,
there's,
we have street lights now,
right?
We have alarm systems.
We don't that,
you know,
you don't need to be looking for paw prints cause there was a tiger around.
You need to be like checking the cell phone and going through his computer on
his emails.
You know,
that's the same impulse.
We're not just going to evolve overnight to catch up with cell phones and street
lights.
Well there's just so many classic there.
There's so many classic stereotypes when it comes to,
to,
to gender roles.
And one of my favorites is the feminist.
That's a always concerned with rape and they constantly have all these,
these rape,
uh,
tweets and rape awareness.
And then you look at them and they're morbidly obese and they have pink hair and
you're like,
well,
what's going on here?
Like what,
why is your entire existence?
Why is he so much of your thoughts?
What have your,
whatever you're projecting online.
So much of it is about gender.
And then they mock men.
Like there's all this Mra mocking.
Like someone called me an Mra and I literally had to Google it because I didn't
know what it meant is that men's rights advocate.
So feminists who mock men who want rights,
which is hilarious.
It's above her.
Well,
let me say so like loaded.
It's all so loaded.
No.
So loaded.
And it's the,
we all the few um,
radical ones give everyone a bad name.
It's like,
does every football player beat up his girlfriend?
No.
Ray Rice did.
So we,
now it's in the zeitgeists.
Well,
I have this woman,
Christina Summers on my podcast a couple of weeks ago and she calls herself the
factual feminist and she's an older woman who grew up as a feminist in a time
where she believes that it had a different meaning.
And it was a true search for quality,
but now she thinks that it's been sort of hijacked with fake facts and bias
statistics and a bunch of studies that aren't really based on reality.
And she,
she read confronts them and she's like,
this is bad for feminism.
When you go around saying that women make 75 cents on the dollar,
this is bad for feminism because what you're not talking about is,
well,
what are the jobs they choose?
And this is the difference between the jobs they choose.
They,
they're not as dangerous.
They don't when they do the same jobs that the difference in pay is very
similar.
Yeah.
Like this.
So this is,
these are disingenuous comparisons and these statistics are biased and,
okay.
Agreed.
And I think that,
you know,
I talked to Maureen Dowd wrote this article or two weekends ago in the New York
Times about less women in Hollywood and less women directors on that kind of
stuff.
And I think that my sort of point,
and she's a friend of mine and we're working on something together,
but I think my point when people ask me about like,
what do you think about less women directors in Hollywood?
And I'm like,
no one is talking about all the offers we get that we pass on.
So no women in late night,
you think that they wouldn't make a show with Amy Poehler right now is the host
of a late show,
right?
They don't cover the women that pass.
Amy Schumer was offered the daily show when she passed.
Right.
No one talks about that.
So it's like I've been offered direct movies and I am directing maybe next year,
but I've said no because it's just not something that I really want to do.
Why are there less female comedians?
It's like,
I mean,
now I feel like there's not as much,
but it's like,
because the lifestyle is fucking stressful.
It's the same reason we might not have our own football league because we don't
want to play a sport where we have to put a helmet on.
It's just like,
you know,
so I think it's a harder gig for a woman stand up.
I think name one female comedian who's married with kids.
I can't,
um,
there was,
there were wanting macfarlane.
Oh yeah,
there you go.
That's right.
But she's married to a comedian and she gets to open for him on the road and
they pass the baby back and forth,
like
comedian soccer,
football.
So that kid probably hits the ground.
She's a child now.
They get to do it together and then you have a great relationship.
Yes.
You're funny together.
And she's very talented as well.
It's a good point.
It's a very good point.
I haven't like,
I mean,
I even struggled if I kept female comedians who have like good relationships are
kind of stable relationships.
So it's not like it's the same thing that you were talking about.
It's hard to find a guy who can deal with a woman that's got a strong
personality.
You want to see my stamina?
What?
No Way.
No fucking way.
I don't let them come see me.
Nope.
It's like,
it's like my dirty little secret.
It's like I'm cheating.
I'm literally will be like cheating on the guy and with with stand up,
I'm like,
I'm gonna run to Starbucks.
Then I'll like go do a set of the comedy store and come home.
Wow.
I will not lie.
I will not let the guy I'm dating see it.
We should probably talk about all this off stage.
I think you,
uh,
there's,
there's work arounds.
I Dunno.
Maybe it's just the wrong guy,
but I think that it's true.
You know what?
So who else said that to me?
It might've been callin.
Actually I do date the I am fine.
I'm a yes,
like a chauvinist.
I was dating like professional athletes and like male models.
Well that's why,
you know,
I said I used to word frantic,
energetic.
There's two,
you've got too much.
Like a lot of men,
you know,
they just don't,
they're not going to match that.
You know?
And sometimes when,
when you see like when people,
like if they hate it,
they hate on someone.
There's a lot of people that hate on like Kevin Hart or someone like that.
Why is he getting a backlash?
We saw ambitious,
ambitious,
and he makes you feel lazy.
Like I'm ambitious and I see Kevin Hart,
I'm like,
I might be lazy.
Yeah.
I might be lazy in comparison to him.
I mean it's really what successful people do,
right?
As they just sort of eliminate our insecurities about ourselves.
They hold a mirror up to what we don't have a lot of people,
they don't do well with that and instead they started attacking that mirror.
Yes.
And I heard a quote a long time ago that stuck with me,
which is that comparison is the worst form of violence against yourself.
And it's one that,
I know
you're probably not a big quotes like inspirational quote person,
but that's one that I stick to whenever I get stuck in the heat.
She's got this and I don't,
and she did this and I did and,
and I'm falling behind and all that sort of,
that's a good way to look at it because instead you should look at it.
It like fuel that uncomfortable feeling that you get when you see someone
kicking ass.
Yeah.
You're supposed to go kick some ass.
Go,
go home and write.
Exactly.
Go workout.
Go.
Yeah.
They have the same 24 hours,
you know,
we do.
Presumably.
And that's how you get better.
Yeah.
Like you don't get better because you're the shit like,
and you're better than everybody.
Like Ah,
wow.
Why would I even try?
Like those days are gone.
That doesn't exist anymore.
There's not this one genius that comes down from the mountain with all the great
ideas.
No.
You have to be surrounded by other people that also have amazing ideas.
Yes.
Each other.
I mean,
it's tricky because I feel like when I hear the word ambitious,
maybe it's to your point about the word bossy and the disruptive leadership
thing.
I feel like when we say a woman is ambitious,
there's this weird,
um,
stink on that word.
Like it gives me like a little bit of,
it makes me recoil a tiny bit cause it makes,
I don't know why,
it's like kind of a dirty word when people say I'm ambitious,
I get uncomfortable.
Um,
but I think for me,
I noticed recently I'm third just turned 33.
I don't need to be famous.
Like that's not something that like I need or I realized that I want,
I think in the beginning I was like,
oh,
I was not seen and heard as a child.
All I want to do is be seen and heard.
And then in the last like three years is I've like done some like work on myself
and woken up.
I'm not like,
like just flying through space unconsciously the way I used to now that's made
things very clear for me in terms of when I wake up in the morning,
what my goals are and how I,
I just want to be good.
I don't want to be famous.
And that makes my life a lot more sort of chill.
And I also think that if I had a relationship with kids,
I wouldn't work as hard.
It's just I don't have kids.
Right.
You know,
when you say you want to be good,
what,
what do you define that by?
D Dee.
Good.
With your standup?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's pretty much every good standup that I know.
And I think you're very funny by the way.
Every person like you.
Anyone that's good.
That's pretty much the most important thing.
Like,
you know,
I do a lot of different shit,
but if anybody ever said,
all right Joe,
you have to pick one only one thing.
It wouldn't even be,
there's not even a thing.
It's,
there's no thought.
Like I could always enjoy conversations with people without putting them in a
podcast.
Yeah.
I can always enjoy watching the UFC without being a commentator.
But w what would you do for free for an occupation?
What,
would you still do it for free or do you stand up for failure?
I don't think I've ever gotten paid to do stand up.
Actually,
I have to lose that.
Honestly.
I've never picked up one of my $50 jives with the comment.
Sorry,
I don't pick a mommy picked him up.
Yeah.
Tommy probably ate them
fucking creep.
But I,
uh,
I think that,
you know,
for the first time,
and I'm curious when you know you're good cause no,
I mean no comedian,
it's comes off stage and he's like crushed it.
We're always just like,
I shouldn't,
I shouldn't suck,
suck,
you know?
And so I know that my last two specials,
I can't even,
why can't I cringe?
Even thinking about them,
it's looking at a photo of yourself in the 80s with what you were wearing.
Your just like,
Oh God.
Like this last one is the first time I wasn't like,
this is great.
It's the first time I was like,
okay,
like I that was,
well,
it's so hard because it's so close to it.
You're there with it all the time.
So none of those jokes were surprising to you.
Nope.
None of those jokes sneak up on you.
And that's what comedy is all about.
Comedy is all about like you have an idea,
you start with a premise and then you say something in that premise.
Like when you say if you start talking about um,
a clock and you started doing a bit about a clock,
you're doing a bit about the clock.
I'm like,
okay,
we're talking about clocks and then you surprise me with some shit.
I'm like,
ah,
that's half of what comedy is.
And that's not available to you because you were saying,
and I know the tree no,
the trick.
So it's so hard to like,
and also you're so close to it because you're chipping away on it and the only
way to be good is to be like constantly introspective and constantly objective
and constantly analytical and it's fucking brutal.
It beats you down.
I just know that if I know that this last one I taped on tape night,
I still kind of giggled at some of the con I still cared.
I still gave a shit about what I was talking about.
I wasn't phoning it in,
I wasn't rote just saying something I had said 600 times and I was like,
I still felt this sense of like I'm saying something I care about,
which to me is all I can ask.
That's the key,
right?
To be in the moment while you're talking about the subject,
right.
It,
you film it and your later,
if a year later it's still relevant to you or matters.
It's like,
okay,
that I've succeeded.
Do you,
this is my thought about standup and tell me if you agree.
I think that when you're,
when you're on,
like everything's going great.
The audience is laughing really loud.
You know,
it's like everyone's tuned in.
I feel like it's a form of hypnosis.
Yes.
It feels now
interesting and I don't,
and I'm actually not bringing this up because of your occupation,
but I think it is very,
standup is very much a sport for me.
Um,
I agree that it's hypnosis.
Yes.
It's very,
it's like,
to me,
the only things I compare it to,
or like sex and boxing because you can't be a second ahead.
You can't be a second behind the other.
The audience is 50% of it.
I can't just do 90% it's like what I do next.
It depends on what you just did and it does become the very like hypnotic
symphonic.
Well,
that's why hecklers don't realize what a fucking disaster they are.
Like how they're fucking things up because you're,
you're fucking up the rhythm of the interaction.
Like all of a sudden you have reared you're ugly head and now everything has to
focus on you and the whole trance has been transformed.
Yes,
totally.
And you've truncated this like vibe.
I am not encouraging this because if I talk about this,
maybe I'll get increased.
The amount of hecklers I get,
I sometimes like hecklers because they keep me awake.
You don't fall asleep at the wheel.
Sometimes I fall asleep at the wheel to do a lot of sets.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
When I'm getting ready for a special,
I'm like good at like trying to time it out.
I'm very embarrassed about this and I have shame around it but I won't write it
out in the word document and I'm a geek.
I record
every set and I do the same set and time it out and have four new tags I'm going
to try.
I try wanted each show like I'm not a savant that gets up on stage and just
writes on stage.
I wish I was that person.
I wish I could pretend like,
I just wish that though I feel like there's shame and maybe this is just like a
high school attitude.
But in comedy there's still that,
you know the person that gets an f is cool.
Like the person who tries the least is the coolest.
Wow.
That's so weird.
That's because you come from athlete.
I,
I feel like people think I'm a nerd because I try so hard and it's so fucking
strange.
Really ought to be a woman thing.
Maybe suppression of the ambitious woman.
Cause I literally have like all my jokes typed out in a word document.
I'd come to the comedy store,
just pretend like I'm winging it and I'm like wow,
I don't know what I'm going to do.
Gives me shit for having a notebook sometimes
to shame a man for like preparing.
That's so good.
Well that's why you're you and he's,
I write shit out.
Two of my favorite things to tell.
I remember one time cause you know what tell has a new hour every six months and
he was like writing in his composition but before a show and I can't remember
what comedian come up to him.
You know,
some middle guy was like,
what are you doing?
What are you writing joke?
Or what are you doing?
And at a tug goes,
I'm writing jokes.
Ever heard of it?
And it was just,
you know,
not particularly funny,
but she's just so like,
yeah,
the greats write shit down.
Try Greg Giraldo and Denis leary going at it
the fucking best.
First of all,
Dennis is sitting there and a leather jacket.
He's got sunglasses on inside during the filming.
Everything's going great for him.
He's on top of the world and Geraldo keeps coming up with these funny lines and
then he goes to this guy,
he's always got lines.
He goes,
yeah,
Dennis,
this is a common,
should we write?
We write down how many writers?
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Gosh,
I don't even have a TV show.
What's your show has actually had a show Dennis canceled.
Mark Marin made fun of me one time about that too.
Like I was on his podcast and he was like,
uh,
he's like,
you like write jokes,
you do like jokes.
And I remember being like,
I'm so,
can we,
I don't,
we isn't that what we're doing here?
Like I was saying that alternative community,
it's very looked down upon to have like debt to bad punchline set up punchline.
He was trying to say that that's a bad thing.
I annoy mark very much.
Why?
Just the fact that I like have jokes and write jokes and prepare and like come
on,
guy has jokes he writes,
Joe does,
but it's a little more,
it feels more unscripted and extemporaneous and like an inner monologue.
Just he's,
you know,
naturally funny or something and I'm not,
I'm not,
not extemporaneously funny.
I have to work.
I'm a geek.
I have to be a geek.
I feel like there's both things.
I think there's benefit in free balling and trying to come up with things and
Improv,
improvising and exploring the bits.
Like,
a lot of times I'll set myself up,
like I'll dig a hole on stage,
on purpose and then try to fight my way out of the hole.
And sometimes I don't.
And that that opens a door to headquarters for sure.
Yeah.
You know,
but you've got to deal with that,
you know?
Um,
but this,
in that process,
like sometimes bits come out,
but I also write,
I sit in front of the fucking keyboard all the time.
I sit in front of a notepad all the time and I feel like if I don't do that,
there are bits that won't emerge.
They just won't.
Nope.
And amount of write them down.
I'll forget them.
And I just,
I was always,
you know,
people always,
people always.
But when people ever,
people say I'm smart,
I get so confused because I got smart because I was not smart enough.
I was always in the kid in class asking a million questions and taking a
million.
Now it's like I work.
So had to overcompensate for the fact that I wasn't smart.
That that's how I,
I think smart's a loaded word too.
It's a very vague nebulous,
it's a nothing word.
Yeah.
Well what do you know?
Like it's,
it's accumulation of information is not necessarily intelligence.
Like there's some people that will say they'll,
they'll try to equate the two together and I think you can learn things you
remember things doesn't necessarily mean you're smart.
You get out of your hands.
Wait Shit.
I,
there's difference between being,
like you're articulate and like you're smart and that way,
like I just read a lot of shit and spouting out facts doesn't make you smart.
That's the same thing I do.
I just bout shit out that I remember.
Yeah.
Right.
I'm not smart.
I'm plagiarizing someone else that I just read.
Exactly.
I'm busy.
I just set a percentage.
And you think I'm smart.
I mean I'm smart about certain things.
Like if you want to ask me about martial arts,
I know a lot about it because I've studied it,
but you're insightful and intuitive and the,
you know,
like an artist when it comes to that kind of stuff.
You're a brilliant with that stuff.
Well thank you.
Cause you have like a sixth sense.
You,
you know,
that's a magical,
yeah,
it's not a sixth sense.
It's just I've been doing it so long.
It's just data chunking.
Well it's like when people,
um,
you know,
and not to demystify sort of what we do or pull the curtain back too much,
when people are like,
you're so good with hecklers.
It's like,
well there's no heckler.
I haven't encountered any exchange I have with a Heckler I've done 500 times.
So at hecklers,
like,
hey bitch.
And they think it's the first time I've ever heard it.
And I'm like,
okay,
do you really want to do comedian club comics?
There's nothing we haven't.
Yeah.
Especially if you work the store cause there's no crowd control.
But do you know,
like I've,
I've had,
there's like so many videos online of me dealing with hackers and be like,
well how do you get so good at that fucking work?
You can't even see them because what people don't understand the common shares
the way Mitzi lidded is you,
you're blinded by the light and you,
they're completely anonymous.
You can't even go,
hey fucking v-neck.
Cause you don't know what anyone's wearing.
Cause you see a black man.
Well there's also this thing that's going on in Hollywood that's very different
than anywhere else where there's a bunch of people that they're not fulfilled.
Like if you come to Pasadena and you do a set in Pasadena,
like those,
a lot of those people are not actors.
So not in Showbiz.
You'd work in Denver.
Those are not showbiz people.
You know what I mean?
You'll occasionally get the non showbiz tackler but a point.
But that was fucking show.
Biz failures are the most bitter weird people you'll ever encounter.
Well,
here's the other thing is I think that every people,
a lot of times that people that come to comedy clubs say they're,
they're the funniest friend in their group.
Oh yeah.
Do you know what I mean?
You always know when the guy's like,
oh,
you're the funny guy in the group.
You're the funny lawyer.
Yeah,
you're the funny lawyer,
but you're the terror.
But you know,
but I don't,
I don't hecklers for some reason.
Don't,
um,
piss me off that much.
I don't know.
Maybe because I'm so sick of my own material.
An insult is like a respite from door.
I know.
I really am,
but I don't totally,
my maybe it's cause I usually agree with them to something when they yell in
Salt.
I'm like,
that's a good point.
I don't know what it is.
They're good natured.
And you know,
sometimes you,
you counter people that are just trying to have fun and those people aren't
nearly as as Shitty as the ones you'll encounter that are just rude.
I am so desperate and I'm interested in your thought on this.
I am so desperate to figure out how to be present because I can't do it.
It doesn't come natural to me to meditate present in the moment I do to Gilgo
no,
I can't do yoga.
I can't do it.
It's not for me.
Uh,
my inner monologue is too treacherous.
The whole idea.
I think most of beat that down.
I'm now doing this meditation practice that's based on John Bowlby's theory of
attachment,
which is a show try to rewire your neural pathways in terms of how we attach to
people.
And when you grew up in a Catholic environment,
your Amygdala doesn't develop the pathways to I think is hippocampus.
And tell me if I'm wrong and bloviating um,
that,
uh,
calms your brain down because you're held such high alert as a kid.
I developed an adrenaline addiction so early on that it's so hard for me to calm
myself down,
which is something I want to mention about smoking.
A,
a doctor told me that,
um,
that,
not that I was going to,
but was saying something about smoking is the inhaling of smoking because you,
when you inhale,
when you smoke,
you take 10 deep breaths.
Let's say if you take 10 deep breaths without a cigarette,
that's going to calm you down.
So sometimes the placebo of smoking is just the inhaling,
which I thought was interesting.
That makes a lot of people go outside and just take 10 deep breaths.
You're going to feel better with or without a cigarette.
You know who Wim Hoff is?
Yeah.
The,
the ice guy climbed to the top of the,
I do his breathing method before.
It's amazing.
Wow.
Have you gotten sick?
Doesn't he say you can control your immune system,
which by the way as you can,
I mean I haven't gotten sick but like I was feeling sick the other night but I
eat a giant chunk of garlic.
My kids are sick.
Like when you have kids they get sick all the time and everybody in the house
gets sick.
Like my wife has a little bit of a cold.
My Yacht,
my middle daughter has a pretty good call.
She's been home from school for a couple of days.
Oh No,
I just ate.
I was feeling little scratchy last night.
Sorry.
Just chunks of garlic,
frank,
all this Kombucha and went to sleep.
Yeah,
I'm fine.
But my immune system is on point.
I bet that mean I'd be interested in if it changed.
It's comedy clubs.
I am telling you though,
something to do with that.
Never get sick,
but it's also healthy food.
I eat really healthy.
I'm like,
come on marrow bone
marrow is my new thing.
Bone marrow game changer.
Do you eat elk?
I don't want,
I was waiting for this to come up.
I follow you on Instagram.
So I'm just worried like I'm not going to go home with so much fucking meat.
You Cook.
You know what I do.
But I pretty much bone broth,
bone marrow and eggs are the only meats I do.
Wow.
Yeah.
Bone marrow,
bone broth.
And so I'm about to go fucking wolf.
I am alone.
I am the lone wolf now.
I'm essentially,
my ex boyfriend used to call me Nell because now remember that Jodi foster movie
where she was raised by wolves cause I got no attention as a kid and all light
cause I have no social skills or people skills.
That's not true at all.
I'm working on it.
I'm getting,
I'm not socialized.
I also have an extra bone in my foot.
I'm not fully evolved.
Like I'm still a primate.
I swear to God you have an extra bone,
your forehead like where?
Like a webbing or like I'm basically um,
have you got your,
um,
what is it?
Your saliva test,
your DNA test thing that they're 23 and me,
you shouldn't vote.
They won't let you vote if you,
if you yeah,
if they see,
so I am in the,
I think 99 percentile of neanderthal deviation.
Really?
Yeah.
So you definitely have some neanderthal.
Oh yeah.
I'm an animal.
I'm a chocolate dark chocolate.
Died like an animal.
Like I eat things like I'll just eat like I was out with um,
a friend of mine the other night and there was like a drink on the,
and I'll just drink other,
like I'll just drink trash.
Like I'm just like,
uh,
I'm like a barn yard culture.
Just the way you grew up.
Yeah,
like I just as like scarcity complex.
If you've never knew when food was coming,
you never knew when you were going to get attention again.
I wasn't socialized.
Like I learned,
I just learned how to make eye contact like two years ago.
I swear to God,
I'm not kidding.
The most basic shit.
I was like not,
I used to look like,
okay,
so I'm looking at you now.
I used to just look here for eye contact and someone like,
I'm looking at the like right side of your head.
And this guy worked with Rob Anderson.
Finally one day was like,
do you know that you're looking at like,
it's like he was like self conscious about like his hairline and I was like,
what?
What are you looking at?
I was like,
what do you mean I'm looking in your eyes?
He's like,
no you're not,
and I asked all my friends,
they're like,
oh yeah,
you always look to the right of our eyebrow.
Like I would just look over here.
I'm looking at your eyebrow right now.
What do you think?
I'm looking at your eyes.
I can't see.
I'm so bad at this.
I don't know.
I'm looking at your right eyebrow right now.
Can you tell kind of like,
here was my question.
I was like,
is the right I supposed to look in the right eye and the left eye is supposed to
look in the left die or do I look like to the center of your nose?
I think as long as you're looking at the eyes,
it's okay.
I think two eyes look at one eye.
That's kind of what I'm doing now.
You know when you're some guys,
this is always insecurity from an insecurity with me.
Some guys when they would fight,
they would look their opponent in the eye.
So aggressive,
so intimate.
I always looked like in the chin,
I look peripherally like abstract.
I see the whole body.
I would always look at people like I know that when I
am on stage and if someone's not laughing or if I'm not connected,
like I'll look them in the eye and then I,
that's how you get them to be obsequious yeah,
that's how you get them.
That's obsequious
you're attacking.
But eye contact is like the most aggressive shit you can think about it.
If someone's,
you're in trader Joe's and someone looks you in the eye or like what you want to
fucking go.
I mean you say hi,
how's it possible that I'm more aggressive than your job?
People make eye contact with me cause you're famous and you know that's what
they're doing.
But if they weren't,
I would just say hi.
If you were in another country and someone just stared at you in the eyes,
Oh,
you looked at them and they didn't look away.
I would think that trying to steal my liver.
Yeah.
Well the chances are you probably are carrying a liver with the amount of meat
you would just have on you at all.
You have had liver read this book called source nutrition or something
nutrition.
It's about how the organs of the animal have more nutrients in the meat.
Oh,
they definitely do.
Yeah.
Wolves always go right to the liver.
That's how they established the alpha.
When they kill something or you've killed a Caribou,
the,
the Alpha Wolf will eat them.
They were first there.
And it's all about how the human evolution of the brain,
uh,
was largely expedited once we started eating bone marrow because humans couldn't
kill their own food in the beginning.
So they would rely on eating the leftovers of wolves in lions and shit.
And what was leftover was always the bones and the shit that they didn't eat.
So they start eating the marrow and then their brains started growing
exponentially and then they were able to start developing tools and hunt their
own food.
Then he started eating meat again because they hunted their own food,
stopped eating the bones and what they thought was the leftover trash and then
sort of plateaued.
It's so fast,
meaning when you think about human beings,
because what I've read is that human beings had been in the shape as far as we
know for roughly 200 plus thousand years,
but we've only been talking for 70.
Wow.
So like our ability to communicate was only established about 70,000 years ago.
So for the first hundred 30 plus thousand years,
there was no talking,
which sometimes talking is just confuses people.
I feel like we can communicate so much better non verbally then we can verbally.
That's not true at all.
I definitely,
I'm being,
um,
what's the word?
MALEC facetious.
Yes.
Um,
I know that I talk too much I should talk about,
but there's always these theories about like why the brain is the size that it
is like the doubling of the human brain size.
Apparently it's like the biggest mystery in the entire fossil record of any
animal.
Like they don't know.
They don't know what it is.
There's all these theories about maybe it was the consumption of more protein,
but then the problem with that theory is,
well what about mountain lions?
How come they don't have giant fucking brains?
What about,
you know,
what about bears?
Why don't they have the biggest brains?
It there's,
then there's the other theories that we developed the throwing arm and that are
throwing arm,
the ability to throw at something and hit it.
It led us to these problem solving skills.
All these different,
cause we figured out,
oh I can develop a tool now I can develop a weapon.
But that doesn't make any sense either.
The most fascinating was Terence Mckenna's cause Terence Mckenna's is,
he has a theory called the stoned ape theory and his is based on silicide and he
believes that.
And the crazy thing about this theory is it coincides with climate change.
Cause 2 million years ago,
the,
uh,
rain forest,
the climate has shifted,
rainforest receded into grasslands and he thinks that these primates came down
from trees and started experimenting with different food sources.
And one of the things he's Angela animals cows and like they would shit and then
these silicide mushrooms would grow on cow patties.
Well they would flip over these 10 cow patties looking for bugs and worms
because they were always underneath there to eat.
But they also had these mushrooms that were growing on the cow patties on a lot
of them were siliciden mushrooms and that the silicide mushrooms,
which were incredibly common in this area.
When you eat them in low doses,
they increased visual acuity to make you horny.
Um,
so that would make a better hunter and more likely to breed.
And then in high doses they have these transcendent psychedelic experiences and
they would allow them to think out of the box,
be more creative,
come up with your right.
Right.
Then also silicide but has been known to regenerate neurons.
Like there's,
there's all these subjects are doing it right
now about the properties or psilocybin.
This pill.
What pill of some mushroom pill?
Sorry,
I keep pointing.
It goes,
I'm going to stop doing,
that's okay.
Point the,
is there a cordyceps shroom tech?
Yes.
This one.
This is Alpha brain.
This is,
this is not mushroom,
cordyceps mushroom,
but it's not the same one from tech.
Same Company.
Same thing that you're talking about right now.
No,
no,
no.
Silicide been his magic mushrooms.
Psychedelic mushrooms.
Okay.
For Real.
You don't have any psychedelic experience?
Nothing can be done.
Mushrooms,
mushrooms.
I did LSD.
Uh,
I still have scars on my,
I'm not calling
myself barring the wall and one.
Um,
no.
I remember the one time I did like acid acid,
like the tabs of acid was in Rehobeth beach,
Maryland.
I'll be Dallas.
Um,
and uh,
we were playing,
do you know the card game asshole?
You know,
were you like we would do,
when you lost the card deck,
you would,
would cut someone's knuckles with the card deck until the white led.
I know hardcore white trash it.
And so I still have like little scars on my knuckles from that.
And then on acid.
Yeah.
And then I like lost my mind,
so I never did that again.
I go hard.
I am a ride or die and it's why I never did acid.
And then I spent the next like 18 hours being like,
this is never going to end.
This is never going to end.
This is all fall.
And then,
um,
I did mushrooms a couple times,
but it's not
go thing.
That's the thing about psychedelics is the bad trips come from the Il and
inability to let go.
I had a hard time with it when I first started doing psychedelics.
Well,
it's like you try to battle it and you can't battle it.
You have to just succumb to it.
Got to give in.
I was 13.
I mean,
I had no
ability.
I had.
Right.
That's crazy.
You're 13.
She's like,
if I did it now,
I probably could,
uh,
acquiesce a little bit,
most likely,
hopefully.
Have you,
uh,
ever done isolation tank?
No,
I did.
You know,
I'm in Gary in Utah.
The Amon.
It's like,
uh,
I did like a debt pervasion tank.
That's different.
Sensory deprivation tank.
Yeah,
same thing.
Different.
Um,
what is an almond Gary relevant Gary.
It's like a,
this like wellness place and they have a giant sensory deprivation tank where
it's like two inches of water.
And you float
in this black.
Yeah.
Paul should be a lot deeper than two inches.
Two inches.
Or maybe it was more than that.
Well,
in order to free your body weight,
however,
however many is required.
12.
Okay.
Now you're just thinking,
oh fat.
No,
no.
I'm saying the person's body.
Yes.
You're two inches smaller than half of your body has to be underwater.
Whatever it is.
Float.
So obviously,
you know,
you're dealing with some maps.
Yes,
yes.
I have to have like 11 inches of water.
Right.
I love how literal you are.
You know what you are.
You're the guy in a fight who you can never win because you just stick to the
literal facts in any one.
Exaggerating is going to lose.
So I feel like you're the guy who was like,
I didn't say,
I didn't say you were a bitch.
I said you were being a bit,
yeah,
I would never do that.
No.
Like,
like on the form,
like you're going to win on a technicality is way to have an argument.
Yeah.
Find that smart guys.
Like I was dating this guy who's a doctor and I could never,
I'd be like,
well,
I mean it's not like you were there.
He's like,
I was there at two 30 I'm like,
but you were late.
He's like,
I was an like stuck to the technicalities.
Well,
I think truly smart people don't get involved in relationships with people that
argue over shit like that.
Interesting.
You got me.
But I'm a comedian,
so I'm,
I don't know if this is cut short chicken or egg.
I tend to exaggerate things.
I'm looking at this.
There's two inches of water I will find.
Yes.
And it screws up my relationships because I think you'll lose credibility.
Everything goes back to you fucking up these relationships with these
relationships,
not going well comedian,
I just,
it's fucked me.
Or maybe it's a crutch.
I lean on to a so that I don't have to just take responsibility for my bank.
It's going to fuck you until you find the right guy and then it'd be great.
Yeah.
It's not that,
it's just,
it's,
it's all,
I mean,
I,
it's the same thing with everybody.
It's like whatever,
it's like some people have personalities that are more compatible with more
people,
but your personality,
I'm sure it's compatible with somebody.
You just gotta find that person who can,
who's,
you know,
the right key.
Do your lock or vice a versa.
Impressed by you because you have your career and your personal life are equally
successful.
This is fortunate,
very lucky,
very lucky.
But also I'd like think about it,
a lot of work on in a lot and you do things,
you know,
I think if you are not like comfortable in either or like I read something today
that made me sad,
I cried,
I crowds,
I'm such a bitch.
I love it.
No,
don't do that.
It's strength.
Check the road.
Um,
it was about Scott Wieland from stone temple pilots and it was a story that his
wife rolling stone one glorify God birthed by tragedy.
So sad addiction is now.
It was not just the addiction,
it was the way he treats his kids,
the way he sort of replaced his children.
He had a son and a daughter with the first wife and then once he got the new
wife and he had a new family,
he replaced his family and he just stopped paying attention to his son,
stopped paying attention to his daughter.
They never went to his new house and all that was just such a bummer.
Addiction.
No is like,
it is nasty.
I,
by the way,
the kids that didn't live with him,
we're probably better off.
Maybe you might be right.
You might be right.
Maybe being raised in addiction and heroin.
God dammit.
Yeah.
I look at Erwin is,
Jerry can never,
you'll never win.
You'll never,
you're right,
you're right.
But I work at it.
I think you have to work at it.
And if you don't work like especially like taking care of kids,
like it's just so fucking important.
I know because you were neglected because I was neglected.
I think we don't,
we have that thing in our head and I am fucking bound and determined to like let
my kids know that I love them,
I care about him and I spent a lot of time with them.
Yeah.
And I'll talk about it too much
time.
It's,
I'm not on my phone cause I had,
I wasn't like alone in a base ignored.
I had people next to me who were not who they were with me,
but they weren't hearing me or seeing me.
I was invisible even though people were around me interacting,
which is sometimes more confusing to a child then just complete absence.
Yeah.
Cause then I'm going,
I'm being rejected on a minute by minute basis by someone who's choosing
something else over me.
So when you,
the most tragic thing is when you see the new alcoholism I think is,
is kids with their parents,
their parents are on their phone right next to them,
completely checked out.
But right next to them.
So you're there,
but you're not.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a really common thing.
But here's what's fucked up.
And this is something that I struggle with and a lot of my friends who have kids
struggle with as well.
A lot of people become interesting because of adversity they faced when they
were children.
And then you have children in the last thing you want is your children to
experience adversity.
Yeah.
And,
but the people that you like,
all come,
ever all my friends came from fucked up households.
Every single one of them.
Well,
the good news is with bullying and your kids will find it.
I'm sure there'll be plenty of adverse,
I hate to break it to you,
but there'll be a lot of adversity.
I would imagine that you can't,
you know,
well,
there's always going to be inside of your sanctuary of your home.
Right.
But,
um,
what I'm saying is the all came from fucked up houses.
This is all,
but there's also no,
you tell me.
I feel like the last generation was just kind of a wash.
Like,
I don't know that many people who had like great childhoods just because like
that generation of men,
alcoholism was so rampant in the fifties I mean people don't think about the
fact that like in the 20s this country had to outlaw drinking.
That's how bad it was for 10 years.
Why it happened though in the 20s
it's not why it happened.
Why did it happen?
It happened because they outlawed marijuana.
Right,
right.
But this is,
this is what happened.
Okay.
They,
what what they did was they
tried to control the population and one of the ways they were going to control
the population was outlawing drinking,
right?
They tried to put a shackle on people cause they didn't want people going out in
the streets and doing these things.
But what they did is they empowered organized crime.
And in doing that,
what they did was they just made al Capone ranch and they made all these people
rich.
And then once they did that,
then they tried to put a stop to other drugs so they can take these people that
they use to enforce the alcohol laws and they enforced other laws.
Like that's when marijuana became elite.
Right,
right.
But all of it,
it's just a control issue.
It's not that it was necessary.
Right.
In fact,
the best way to keep people from drinking is to let people drink around them.
See the disastrous effects.
Like this is why you don't like,
you're in all these groups,
why you went all these groups,
you in all these groups cause you grew up with people that were fucked up.
Yeah.
You know,
I never touched coke.
And one of the reasons why I never touched coke because I grew up with coke
heads,
right.
I had coke heads that were friends of mine.
One of my good friend's cousin was a coke head and I saw it from a bunch of
people.
And then I had a buddy who died from heroin.
Yeah.
I've never,
I've never even thought about dying.
Yep.
So when you tell people they can't do something,
they want to do it more.
So like in Europe,
I mean there's a lot of alcoholism but it's not like as bad as it is here
because it's like yeah,
go for it.
They drink at 14 and they've got it out of their system and they have nothing to
prove and there's not,
yeah,
exactly.
They let kids try driving around it.
I think it was more of a control issue than it was anything.
And it all coincided with World War One and I think,
you know,
there was a bunch of people that wanted everyone to get back to work and make
America strong.
But you need to just create slaves.
You can't tell people what they can and can't do with their body.
You just can't.
You can't.
And then initially because drinking is fun,
I like it for fun.
And,
and then in the fifties the fucking mad men generation,
the three Martini lunch,
like people were just drinking during the day at the office.
It was socially acceptable.
So that was our parents and our parent's parents were the first generation.
I mean,
trying to be good parents that even have the information to be able to be good
parents and we have the information on the psychology and the sociology and
alcoholism.
Like you're the first parent that's going like,
you know what,
I'm going to see my kid and let my kid cry and let my,
if I have a boy I'm gonna let him say like I don't feel good and not be like man
up and catch this ball.
You know,
it's the first generation that I feel like we're really um,
know enough to be able to be good parents.
What'd you gotta know when to tell them the man up too though?
Yes,
of course.
The one to walk it off,
you know,
like,
like my five year old,
she'll cry where everything cause she knows the crying gets her attention.
Yeah.
And then I'll go,
look sweetie,
if you want a hug,
I'm happy to give you a hug.
But I know that that didn't hurt.
I saw what happened.
Yes.
There's really nothing she can enable.
Victimizing yourself willy.
Willy hurt cause she's five so she still has a lot of extra W's.
Yeah.
They put wheelie topped up my foot.
This like all these woo woo woo noise cause there's still have like honeybees,
your daddy's Joe Rogan.
You did a man the fuck up right now.
Suck it up.
You're embarrassing me.
Be Fine if we didn't love.
But you also let them know.
Yeah.
But I don't ignore,
I don't go,
hey stop fucking crying.
Yeah.
If your foot's fine and don't say that.
I go look,
you got to let it go.
It's just a sensation.
Yeah.
You know I read this thing,
there's this book called the fantasy bond.
Um,
about uh,
what happens when kids are ignored,
neglect and all that kind of stuff at kids would rather be physically abused and
then ignored.
Yeah.
I've read that because at least they're getting their,
their existence is being validated and they don't,
they don't feel like their life is at stake.
I dated this girl and we broke up.
She dated some guy that hit her and I've told this story before,
but it was very bizarre.
It was a long time ago.
It was a long time.
Okay.
Hit me up.
I was like 17 at the time.
Um,
but she was telling me that this guy hit her and I was like,
fuck.
And she's like,
you know what's fucked up is I like it.
And I was like,
whoa.
Context easy.
You don't want him to like hit you because you,
you know the thing in the dishwasher,
you want the light slap in bed.
I don't think it was a light slap.
I think there was like some beating up.
It was weird.
But also,
did he,
was he trained in Jujitsu?
Like you,
I don't think she'd want you to hit her.
Some random guy who's not trained fighter.
Yeah.
Shit.
He text me.
Hey,
I'm fine with Tony Hinchcliffe hitting me.
I don't want Joe Rogan.
Tony's like
Vegan.
Tony Hinchcliffe got off the Vegan.
No,
we're back influenced him.
Okay.
There you go to the gym a few times.
So look,
you're not going to get this weight and beans.
Okay.
Maybe not him,
but yeah,
I think it's like,
depends on who's doing the hitting.
I wasn't even there when he hit me.
He did it last week for the first time I went to Fogo the child,
you know that places the Brazilian steakhouse.
I know what you're talking about.
Fucking meat.
Do you know my arch fair story about when he hazed me,
please use me at the comedy store.
He's June the beginning when I started the Commissar Hill.
I think he,
we told the story on his podcast but yeah,
he mentioned it.
Which is that like in the beginning when I got,
hey,
it's so hard,
you are not there to protect me because you had made your mass exodus from the
comic store.
It was like him and like David Taylor and all these guys used to just fucking
kill me.
I mean they would just make my life miserable because I was like showed up in my
backpack and like,
you know,
Hoodie and I was like,
had,
she was like,
I'm going to make it as a comedian.
And they were like,
we're going to crush your soul.
And One Night Ari,
stall my backpack and hit it because I would always come with a backpack.
But he didn't know that my credit card had just gotten stolen and I just got a
call from the bank saying,
Hey,
some guy stole your credit card.
So he was like,
it's probably someone around you who stole your credit card,
copied it,
et cetera.
And then Ari stole my book bag,
put it like up in the back bar,
like hit it.
And then I instantly,
I couldn't find it,
started hysterically crying and made Tommy turn on the house lights in the or,
which have you ever even seen lights on in the ocean?
It's very weird.
She goes in there looking at a one night stand in the face.
Yeah,
totally.
And uh,
and yeah,
and he didn't admit that it was him for like a years until,
I think like seven years later was he was so like embarrassed or upset or
whatever.
That's probably not the word.
I don't think he is out of these capable of that.
Those are those kind of emotions.
But he then admitted to me finally that was made that stole your backpack.
Wow.
Yeah.
That didn't seem,
that wasn't as good as story telling him.
Do you think there is a concerted effort to fuck with women when they start
doing standup comedy?
Fuck with them emotionally,
obviously.
Mentally.
Yeah.
And I'm grateful for it.
I'm glad they did.
I'm grateful they made me tougher.
You say though,
not a lot of women would say that.
Right?
Look,
I know maybe I'm not being feminist or Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
But I heard again,
I know,
I know.
That's why I'm,
that's why I said it with a tinge on it because I,
I again,
because I grew up playing sports,
I welcome adversity cause I know it makes me stronger so I don't complain about
it.
I know like pain,
muscle soreness,
all that stuff.
Like if I'm not sore after a workout the next day I'm bummed because I know that
I didn't work that hard.
So adversity at the comedy store and stuff I like knew instinctively you guys
are helping me.
You don't know you're helping me.
You're cause you're trying to hurt me,
but you're actually making me stronger and I'm grateful.
That's a very unusual attitude though,
right?
Even for men or a woman.
Yeah,
for anybody.
And when you grow.
I grew up in an environment that was very like,
you know,
idle hands is the devil's work and if it doesn't hurt you're not doing it right.
Yeah.
So I'm grateful that I have that mentality because it,
it helps in doing standup.
So you stop for three months,
you've stopped for three months time it these decide three months sort of like,
I think stand up for me is very much like a haunting,
you know,
you get an Itch,
you sort of like have stuff you have to talk about and instead of like boring
your friends at dinner with it or you have a podcast,
you have other outlets.
I wait till I'm like,
this is a gross word,
but like constipated with like an obsession of injustice.
Like right now there's nothing that's like keeping me up at night.
That's me that I have to get on stage and yell about.
And I,
if,
if I'm not obsessed with it,
why would I waste an audience member's time?
So when did you do your special?
Is first week of September.
Okay.
So when do you think you'll start getting that itch?
You're like a month.
I need to go on a couple of bad dates and like get pissed on or something,
you know,
cause they just did,
I did 50 cities in a year or something and like said so much.
And now I need to like get that 50 cities and I think I did figure out is this
like every week or is it like dude,
several different cities a week?
Uh,
yeah,
I was doing like Friday,
Saturday,
like one city Friday,
one city's Saturday,
sometimes one Sunday.
Where'd you film
for?
Like Santa Monica?
No,
I knew upset.
This is such a dorky comedian thing.
My new obsession is to do and my did.
My last one in Irvine,
my new obsession is to go all around the country to tour.
And then when you shoot your special sleep in your own bed,
get your crew,
get your everybody and,
and shoot it here.
So I shut my last one in Irvine and then this one in Santa Monica and Santa
Monica,
the brode theater on Santa Monica College.
It's a beautiful theater.
I wanted it to feel like a club.
500 seats.
Gorgeous.
Looks like a spaceship,
you know,
cause when you shoot and you know I loved your,
the one you did in Denver,
but when you,
and I would love to,
I've been obsessed with shooting special at comedy works in Denver.
The um,
the other way you did the downtown one.
I love the other,
uh,
Tim looks like it.
It's gorgeous.
Letterman square one.
And I was like,
should I do that?
But then you're in,
you're in a hotel and you're not and then the night out and then you're tired
and you don't have your restaurant,
you've got to get up and you're in a hotel room and you're like,
where's food?
And it just throws off your rhythm.
So my indulgence is to shoot a special in sleep in my bed the night before and
then after.
That's fucking smart,
you know,
cause no one be comfortable.
See you,
your last batch of the Denver one,
you talked about Denver and weed and that got into legalization,
we and all that kind of stuff.
But it's like,
for me it's like,
I don't think most people give a shit where you shoot it unless you make it a
cornerstone of what you're doing.
So it's like I'm going to go all the way to Chicago to shoot it for no one cares
that I've schlepped all the way to Chicago.
You know?
Isn't that my ego?
It's in your mind.
I think.
Yeah,
maybe.
I feel like for me,
and maybe it's just cause I'm a girl and I need my shit and my makeup artists,
I'm like fucking hair extensions and if I don't,
if I don't sleep eight hours,
I look like Steve Buscemi like I can't fuck around.
So being on the road is just,
I think that's where the being the girl comes in.
It just gets a little more complicated because when people are like,
is it harder?
Being a female comedian,
I'm like literally the differences I need my shit.
My like makeup,
I have to like schlepped my have to check luggage.
When I travel a furrowed one night,
I'm bound and determined to do all my specials from now on in smaller places.
Why would it bigger places all ego,
no one cares.
Like when you're watching at home,
you're sitting in your living room and you're sitting on a couch.
It loses all the magic,
all the scope it no one cares and no one's doing oh look so and so sold 2000
tickets and Kevin Hart,
I like no one cares,
nobody cares.
And I don't even do audience reaction shots anymore.
It's for ego.
And then it also dates the special because number one,
if you can see the audience,
it's too brightly lit.
Number two,
you cut to it and then you see the like,
you know Ross Perot t shirt so you'd know exactly what like,
it's like
nothing throws me off more than seeing a no fear tee shirt.
And I'm like,
oh,
that was shot in 1998 it takes away the timeless classic thing.
There's definitely some assholes in shorts and you're like,
Oh God,
I just think that that's a cheap way to cut away.
Cut away the director and he,
this was fucking insisting on that.
He wanted to keep the room that we had a fight about,
like even turned the lights
up during the first showing.
I was like,
why the fuck are the lights on?
We had like a problem with it.
Standup specials are so fascinating to me because it's like we get so good at
something that's incredibly hard.
That's very much thought of is one of the hardest things you can do.
I mean,
how many people can get up on a stage and make a crowd laugh for an hour?
How many,
how many of you think housing and the housing in the world?
Maybe really good ones for an hour to kill it for an hour and might be a
thousand in the country.
Maybe.
I mean there's more,
there's more heart surgeons where I think if you really had to be honest,
how many do you think are great?
How many do you think are really funny?
When I have set the hundred,
I would say 500
300 million people,
plus in this country,
three 50 with Mexicans.
I think that's,
uh,
that's probably write 500 people.
And I mean,
how many hearts surgeons are there?
How many neurosurgeons are there?
Oh,
thank God.
There's bond tons.
So it's like this is such a weird specialized thing.
And then we get so good at something that's so few people can get good at.
That's so hard.
I hope this doesn't come off like ego maniacal.
But um,
and then all of a sudden you're shooting your special,
the taping.
And then we changed the circumstances entirely.
We'd make it light.
We do it at 6:00 PM instead of an eight.
We totally changed the circuit.
We changed the rules of the game the one night that it really matters the most.
Boom.
Cameras flying around.
There's stay behind me now.
I wear high heels and wear your hair down and you've never worn your hair down
and stand up before.
But the night that accounts are gonna wear your hair down and have makeup on.
It's just like,
so I tried to make the night that I shoot the special as replicate at night at a
normal night of the club as much as possible.
Same lighting,
same number of people.
I was only like 400 people,
you know,
no cameras in my face.
This,
my hair is down in this and it was a very big drama that my hair was down
because HBO wanted my hair to be down.
I was like,
I've never wore my hair down and doing stand up.
People want your hair to be done.
Well,
this is actually kind of a funny story.
Apparently Chris Rock suggested to them that I put my hair down.
Fuck Chris.
Jaime.
Yeah.
What does he know that calm and know about your hair?
He,
he did it.
I can battery called good hair.
What does he,
that's like me telling you not to wear makeup.
It's very,
it don't wear lipstick bitch.
I don't wear lipstick.
I
look,
I'm a fan of his and he's smart and he told Hbo that and then they were like,
we want you to wear your hair down.
And I was like,
no,
no.
Fuck.
I know.
I got to know Chris rock get the fuck Outta here.
And I was like,
look,
I had some,
I do believe in kind of things that not always my ideas are the best ideas and
maybe other people know more than I do,
especially people who are doing comedy for 30 years.
So I just decided to do it.
And do you feel weird?
I felt very weird.
I felt like I was being attacked by like a wild animal the entire time.
You see me like my hair,
like forgetting and I'm like super tweaked out in the special because my hair is
attacking me the whole time.
But yeah,
it's like,
it's like playing a sport with your hair down.
That's what it felt like to me.
Yeah.
And it's,
and you've got muscle memory and you've got all of the sudden I'm fighting it,
but anything that throws a curve ball at me while I'm performing,
I welcome because it keeps me present.
Well,
especially something that throws a curve ball at you while you're doing a
special,
it's not just performing,
you're performing something that's going to be like a walk down forever.
Yeah.
But that's what I think we are best at having shit thrown in us and US having to
deal with it.
Sure,
sure.
But like sometimes it's not representative of the actual material itself and its
best form.
Never.
Well,
I mean there's,
you ideally never do the same show twice.
So I think for me and the first couple it was all about how do I do the same
thing every time like acting or something.
Like how do I replicate the same thing and then as I grow more as a comedian I'm
like how do I not do the same thing in a perfunctory phoned in way every time.
Right.
How do you have just a real present performance and then also be aware that
you're filming this.
Yes.
How do I like nail it but also like be fresh and surprise myself.
Isn't that why it's important to do more than one show in a night?
I think that's super important.
I actually did one show Friday watch Saturday.
That's great.
Yeah,
it was actually great.
I mean that's the benefit of HBO has,
they have a little more money.
But that was helpful to me because the first show was just working out the kinks
with the camera guys so that you know you do a great performance and God forbid
they don't want to catch it and you're like fuck,
but you're really trying to catch lightening in a bottle and a special,
I mean when you do one show,
do you ever see Bill Hicks is relentless?
I mean,
yeah,
it's on Youtube.
It's kind of flat and one of the reasons why it's kind of flat as he did one
show in a theater in London and it was for HBO.
So it's like this one didn't do too.
No one.
Also the same thing with multicam.
I think a lot of the reason people think multicam suck is that it's like,
it's like filming a play,
being there,
stand up is meant to be live.
It's if you're watching it on Netflix or if you're watching an HBO,
you're getting like an in its second iteration.
Like it's always going to lose 40% of the magic.
I mean,
you go see Joe Rogan at the,
uh,
um,
fucking comedy works.
You're dying every joke,
clapping,
fucking slapping her knee going crazy and then you watch it and you're like
laughing out loud.
But it's just the different,
we are not in the flesh in front of me.
Yeah.
You're not caught up in the trance.
You're not in that five.
Same with multi cams.
Like,
you know,
we'll shoot like an um,
uh,
an episode of something and I swear when it's there,
it's funny.
We're all like,
that was so funny.
The audience is going crazy and everyone's laughing and then you go see it in
the editing room and you're like so much funny.
If you'd been there always this weird about being there while someone's
performing music too.
You know,
you go to like really good music,
you like really good music and you listen to it,
it's great.
But if you go see someone do it live,
it's like,
I rarely get to see people perform like music wise.
I mean seal,
I see a lot of standup.
It's so rare that I get
to see music.
I went and saw,
um,
Justin,
Tim,
when I was in Vegas at a year,
we're in Vegas a lot of times at the same time.
We,
I was in Vegas,
uh,
and after the show I went and saw Justin Timberlake and I was like,
after the show?
After my show,
yeah.
And then I went,
he does a three hour show.
By the way,
Jesus creed.
It's three hours.
It was dancing the entire time.
Like Michael Jackson.
I had to sit down 45 minutes of watching his show cause my backyard,
and he was dancing for three hours.
That motherfucker does not play.
I want to know what he's up to,
what he's putting in his joints.
He's at semen.
It really is very tissue regenerating.
No,
in that case,
I'd be 12 feet tall.
And so I was watching him.
I was just like,
holy fuck.
Like I was like,
he is amazing.
Like he,
he dazzled me.
I was dazzled and I was like,
is it news to you that Justin Timberlake is talented?
And I was like,
no,
I'm just used to seeing it on tiny screens.
Right,
right.
You know,
I'm you.
That's the same reason that you know,
people can come up to us in airports and go,
Joe,
what's up man?
What did you fucking eat for breakfast?
We're on small screens and then when an actor's on big screens,
people that come got to look over that.
That's Brad Pitt.
They don't go up to him.
Ask him what he's eating.
Do you ever take a picture with people and you feel them shaking?
Yes.
How weird is this?
Very,
very feel.
Their,
their body shaking.
It's just so weird to me because I don't,
I have such career body dysmorphia but also career dysmorphia and it varies.
Shocking.
I'm always like,
she thinks I'm sure as a Lumberman who does she think I am?
Well,
women like are really powerful woman.
Like you,
like women.
Like,
oh my God,
you're right.
They're like,
yeah,
I love you.
You're my idol.
Like you wouldn't want to be like,
a lot of women want to be assertive and powerful and they want,
they just want to feel confident and they look at you.
You're on stage,
you're talking about sex and you're talking all this crazy shit and you're
saying it in a funny way and people are laughing and you have that.
Your assertion and the way you're annunciating is all this clear and the,
I can't do that shit.
You know,
and then
I cannot,
no.
Oh,
I'm so scared and insecure.
I can't not do standup.
I'm the opposite.
I'm so terrified of being invisible and no one,
I literally do stand up out of weakness,
not abstract,
but I do not operate.
My motives are completely out of like insecurity and fear.
It's funny though,
the talk about Indian mid dot though.
That's what makes it really rare because most people who would feel those things
would just like shut up.
Yeah.
Put 'em in a closet there.
Good point.
I need to fucking hammer boards on the closet.
I need to work on line more.
Um,
I did try to impress you today.
I put a eyeliner or a eyebrow pencil on and I feel like if melting off,
press me not to.
I'm a big fan of eyebrows.
Really.
No,
you're right.
It does is I don't even know yet the entire dot till I had to look at the one
eyebrow to not look in your eyes.
I see what that would be like.
I just noticed that you had eyebrows.
No eye contact.
No,
but I mean,
I stand up for me is completely fear driven.
It's not confidence.
I'm good.
I'm doing,
I'm afraid that I feel like you've never done what you just did before.
Yes,
definitely.
I'm out of Ammo.
I so can't remember.
Does your wife fill in her eyebrows?
I don't know.
I don't know your wife at all.
That's so funny that there's that.
You don't know that about your wife?
Um,
I want to ask questions.
Yeah,
smart.
Uh,
they,
I sometimes at night smoke weed and start plucking my eyebrows and then I wake
up the next morning and they're just half the size and I'm just like,
fuck,
did I get a new face last night?
So I put the tweezers,
I can't smoke weed and have tweezers in the house.
And then so like three nights ago I tweeze like an entire chunk out of my
eyebrows type to fill it in with an eyebrow pencil.
Hashtag feminism you should,
you should smoke weed and do yoga.
Maybe you would like it.
Then here's the problem with me and exercise.
I really like to feel,
I need to feel some kind of pain and feel like I'm burning so many calories.
Think of Yoga is exercise.
There you go.
Smart as body maintenance smart because of the stretching,
moving meditation.
For me it's been,
it's like really helpful for me mentally,
but it's also really helpful for my body because everything I do is like,
yes,
yes.
It's all explosion.
Fucking,
yeah,
well just stretching especially because mobile people,
which I have,
which is that we use are our bones instead of our muscles,
which is a lot of people.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
I don't understand what that means basically means like so I can like like knock
my hip out of like,
I'm just like too flexible.
Basically my hips are just lab,
just Janky.
I'm a lemon.
You're very,
yeah,
I'm very flexible.
My hips can pop out of socket and when I like when I pop out a second and then
when I um,
like would run and walk,
I would walk with my bones,
my hips and my knees instead of my quad muscles.
Does that make sense?
You would be a good striker cause it's one of the things that you,
when you teaching martial arts,
one of the things I would teach people them back when I used to teach is you got
to think about you're using your bones.
Don't think about your muscle,
think about fighting with your bones.
Yeah because that's the way to do it correctly is like mechanically you have to
be using your bones.
You can't think about using your muscles cause then you're like ah yes
everything becomes circular and she's trying to use your muscles but we were
trying to use your bones.
Everything is like done correctly.
If you do it correctly,
interest as much more effortless than it seems like if you watch like some of
the best strikers,
they strike in a sort of an effortless way.
Miss the guys that do it kinetically and they use a lot of muscle that get the
job done,
but efficiency like the best way to do it efficiently.
It's kind of been mapped out and the way they do it correctly,
it's almost like seems counterintuitive.
But you're using your skeleton.
Do you know Martin Snow?
No,
he's got a gym called Trinity,
uh,
boxing on Melrose I think.
And his was,
he was um,
helping me with the,
what are those little things you put in pools that help you float?
Floating.
He would hit me.
Punched the floaty thing.
Boxing trainers.
Yeah,
exactly.
So that I would do,
so I would do that.
What exactly what you're talking about because I would try to hit to,
cause I'm too much.
I'm alive,
I'm too
much.
But yeah,
so I was putting so much
pressure on my knees and my hips and my ass.
I had no ass development at all.
Like I wouldn't use my ass.
I would use my back if I was going to live something,
I would use my vertebrae.
Dangerous.
Yes.
Instead of,
and then what happens is if your debt over time,
that's how we get non collision injuries.
When you just add 55 you sneeze and throw out your back.
It's just so much pressure is built up on your bonds micro.
You know when people are like I just sat on the couch and throughout my neck,
you know,
stuff like that.
I did that once in the fucking in the shower.
I like turned to grab the shampoo or something like that.
Ah Yes.
Yeah.
Just hits you.
But it's a straw that breaks the camel's back.
It's like the straw that breaks the camel's back.
And I had to drive to Vegas and this is a long time ago in my car driving.
I remember I couldn't turn around and look behind me.
So when I had to look behind me I'd literally have to [inaudible].
So for you is yoga about stretching and my mind too,
I know my mind cause it cause I have the same sort of internal dialogue issues
and I'm sure you probably do.
So I just dialogue.
That means you have to,
there's a bunch of people that's a monologue.
Animals and
plants.
There's all sorts of shit going on there.
Yeah.
As elves,
there's lot of stuff going on in my head that's about keeping it together.
Yeah.
That's what it's about.
No,
I know that that's the next thing.
I just,
I have so many prejudices against Yoga I have yet.
You might be the first person I have yet to meet someone who does yoga,
who is not batshit crazy
or annoying or knowing,
oh,
I can literally every whole foods parking lot is a bunch of people with yoga
mats being complete asshole.
I'm like,
just cause you have the yoga mat doesn't mean you're cool.
Like it's fair that I've meet someone who does yoga,
who abides by the principles of yoga at all.
It's hard.
You can find this all like anorexic,
unemployed people.
What's also where we live.
That's true.
We live in a place where everybody's trying to reinvent themselves or pretend to
be something.
We create this false narrative that's,
that's,
that's a giant part of why we're here.
We are.
We're in this like magnet.
Okay.
This Hollywood attention magnet and all these metal filings use people that just
so desperately want to be special.
They come to this place and if they don't feel like they're special,
they go,
well that guy seems special.
What's he doing?
Well he's wearing wooden beads and he likes yoga.
I got some of the wrongdoing.
No mass day I'm doing,
yeah,
I'm eating Tofu.
I don't even,
I don't,
yeah,
no animals were harmed.
Modified.
It's,
no.
Yeah,
I and I also am like at this place,
I don't know where you are on this.
I'm like on self improvement overwhelm.
So it's like,
it's by the time I do all the things I need to do to improve myself.
It's like four 30 by the time you go to like therapy and work out and meditate
and yoga.
It's like I don't even have time to,
it's a full time job to try to take care of yourself.
It's definitely a full time job if you do it right and that's why it's really
hard for people that have full time jobs.
Yeah.
To take care of themselves.
You find it overwhelming.
Yeah.
We get out of shape,
you get tired.
You know,
you can't indulge in hobbies.
If you're a full time job and you have a family and God forbid you're behind on
your bills,
so then you have to work over time or pick up a second job.
Like it's a luxury to not be crazy and it's a luxury to not have like the body
trauma and to hurt your,
you know,
it's like I go to this woman who helps me cry,
the grit woman to help the crime.
This Israeli can help you cry.
I was like,
see,
I just figured out what was wrong with me.
I thought that was hot.
I just learned everything I need to know about myself.
I failed that Roderick Tass um,
she,
um,
her whole thing is that you,
your basically your body's a blueprint to everything that ever happened to you
and as a kid,
all the trauma and emotions that you were pressed or like held in your muscles
and because of our bodies react faster than our brains.
Is that true to something that if as a kid,
if I was abused and I used to do this,
I'm flinching.
For those of you listening,
uh,
as an adult,
if I flinch at something,
all of a sudden it's going to signal my hippocampus.
They make bill,
it tells me hippocampus,
something bad is happening.
Even if it's not okay.
You know,
for thinking shit,
is that possible?
Probably.
You go to a chick to make you cry.
Go for a jog.
Cried until I was like 27 what?
I never cried.
I never,
so I have all this like the bane of my existence.
Real estate.
No,
that's why you're healthy and that it's release.
Crying is a solution.
Not a problem.
Yeah.
Well I don't cry about,
shoot with me though.
That's what's weird.
You didn't happen to me.
Doesn't make me cry.
Interesting Shit that happens to other people,
other people's tragedies and bads and even sometimes positive things,
right?
That's healthy.
I learned that crying is a weakness and you're not allowed to cry.
And if you do cry,
you're going to attract attention of dangerous people who are just going to make
things worse.
So just like pretend like everything's fine.
Well I think that this,
that there's whatever crying is this overwhelming emotion that that is also like
horsepower but overwhelming emotion when it's manifested itself or when,
when it's manifested in a positive way or like when you turn it on and use it in
some way like you'll for something else.
Well I think when someone says to you,
this is like your thing,
right?
That you're a lot with this.
That's what that is.
What they're saying is,
I mean even though it makes you feel uncomfortable because you're insecure
because you have this like the self judging thing.
What that is is you got a lot of fucking horsepower.
There's a lot of shit going on.
It's a lot of it.
So when you funnel that stuff into something,
you can achieve spectacular results.
And that a lot of people that are like doll or they're,
they're just,
there's not much going on there.
They can't do that.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's the difference.
Like it will overwhelm you in a negative way.
It'll it,
it'll fucking burn your house down if you don't control it.
Yeah.
But whatever it is,
when you focus in on something,
you can do some shit that other people can't do.
But then it's like this balancing act of trying to keep this fucking tiger in
under control.
Yeah.
And that's that tiger is your mind,
your emotions,
your,
your being,
whatever the fuck you are.
You know?
And some people just have more of it.
There's some people that are just more Olin
pure.
And I would interested in your take on this is that I wonder if,
because I was very nervous when I like decided,
okay,
I'm going to to heal my,
I'm going to fix all these invisible wounds.
I'm going to like fix all this brokenness of like,
will I still be funny?
Well,
I still be ambitious.
Oh to a real problem with that.
When I was young,
I'm,
what if I get mentally healthy while I still be funny
tap dance for people.
When I was like in my early twenties,
I used to like,
there was always the concept that I would always chase as a martial artist,
the chase,
this concept of enlightenment,
this unachievable goal of being complete total control of your mind and being
present at all times and being just absent of weakness.
Right.
You,
you,
you fix yourself.
You get to this point where you're operating this pure zen state in competition.
That's what I chased all throughout my,
my youth and all through my teenage years up until I started doing comedy.
And then when I started doing comedy,
I,
uh,
I was at this weird place where I was like,
I shouldn't like try to meditate and I shouldn't try to calm myself because I
should be kind of fucked up.
Cause that's all the great ones.
Like whether it was prior or Kinison,
which is,
they're all fucked up.
Yup.
Lenny Bruce,
Dow gray prior would have been if he was a little more sober.
How long?
Much?
La,
who knows?
I don't know,
but I was like,
okay,
I cannot,
um,
I mean I'm killing myself.
Right.
It's like,
I can't live this way anymore.
And if,
if,
if I'm only doing comedy because I'm fucked up,
I probably shouldn't be doing comedy.
That's the club.
You know,
like Scott Wieland's wife was talking about,
yeah,
we're fine.
Tragedy and glorifying elimination addiction.
Yeah.
You know,
actually that fucking drug,
God dammit.
I hate that.
Fucking nineties.
So nine.
Yep.
It's 2015 now because all the people that are addicted to pills,
Anthony Bordain did a show recently about Massachusetts and one of the things
that they were talking about in the Massachusetts show 'em of his show,
I'm on Coleman,
Howard's moving car parts unknown.
Um,
he,
he was talking about these people who they were interviewing because you know,
Anthony had a serious heroin problem when he was younger and he was talking
about all these people that became addicted to heroin because they got on pills
and it was so easy to get.
And then they were prescribing and like fucking crazy.
Yeah.
When I got my nose fixed,
my doctor prescribed me two different opioids.
Yeah.
What?
And I didn't take any of it.
I was like,
man,
my nose doesn't even hurt,
man.
Yeah.
It was like mildly uncomfortable once it was done.
But they get that addiction and then they change the laws,
made it much more difficult to get the pills.
And then people got desperate because they were addicted and they need it.
And then they went to heroin and they were talking about this overwhelming
heroin issue in western Massachusetts.
I guess a lot of parts of our country.
Yeah,
I mean a lot.
I mean,
just the more I learned about addiction,
this Garrett are more scared I got because a lot of it is genetic too.
You know,
they say,
um,
uh,
genetics loads.
The gun environment pulls the trigger for drugs,
you know,
so I know that's in my genetics.
It's a tattoo.
Some really hot girl who I met Ahmed dates.
Um,
and uh,
I know that because I am an addict,
I just,
my drug is not substances.
My drug is control and work and people who aren't,
you know,
and adrenaline do,
because adrenaline is an addictive substance and you can get addicted to
adrenaline in Utero if your mother is under stress,
it's called,
um,
epigenetic imprinting,
whatever chemicals that your mother is producing and you'd order your,
so if your mother in Utero is producing,
uh,
the adrenaline and cortisol,
you're going to get addicted to that very young.
So I was an adrenaline addict when I was out of the gate.
And so,
uh,
yeah,
so
Michael Irvin was telling me that Michael Irvin was telling me about the problem
with young kids that were raised in really
horrible environments,
violence and crime and we constantly in fight and flight mode when you were
around violence all the time,
your body just becomes a engineered to handle that yes.
From the wound.
Yes.
And I found that I,
and this is sort of what half of what I'm in recovery for is that,
um,
I found that I felt very comfortable in dangerous situations and in completely
benign situations felt fear.
Do you think that's because in dangerous situations it's like the circumstances
are already late.
Familiar.
I know how to handle this.
Yeah.
Right.
In drug addict,
someone being abusive,
violent.
This is my comfort zone,
right?
This has given me the,
uh,
adrenaline quota that I need.
This is what I'm designed for.
I'm in the ring.
I only know how to live with my gloves on when the gloves are off.
That's when I could concern cause I'm waiting for the other shoe to drop.
And then you're also in your own head and it's like spiral out of control.
Hyper vigilant,
hypervigilant,
you know?
And because in my own growing up silence meant it's a calm before the storm.
Oh Man.
Things were calm and men,
someone's about to come home drunk.
Someone's about to Shit's about to hit the fan.
So it's very hard for me to relax,
which is probably why yoga is hard for me cause it's like when's the other shoe
going to drop?
Well,
you know,
it's interesting,
the PTSD is a huge problem with soldiers.
But yeah,
I talked to a lot of guys that were special forces guys,
like special ops with the Rangers or Green Berets or navy seals.
They don't have nearly as much of a problem.
Interesting.
Because they're the antagonists.
Mm.
Yes sir.
They create the drama
diff guys.
They're going out,
they're in control.
They're going out and to going there,
hunting down people.
Whereas the guys were sitting around waiting to be attacked.
Yes.
Those are the ones that are freaking out.
Creditors versus the ones who were stationed in a place and they're being
attacked all the time.
Those guys get rattled in there.
I would also
be fascinated in the special forces.
A couple of things that interest me about them is that,
number one,
the ones that have the most PTSD and depression when they come home are the ones
that didn't kill anyone because they feel guilt and shame.
Really?
Yup.
That they kill anyone.
Really?
Yes.
There is this,
I'll send it to you.
I dated a guy who was really into seals and made a movie about navy seals and
stuff.
Um,
and then,
uh,
so they probably,
because they're again,
like the perpetrators like you said.
Um,
and I would imagine,
I'm curious if it's chicken or an egg,
the guy that the guys that end up being navy seals if there,
I don't want to say sociopathic that's being extreme,
but like if they became seals because they have less of a,
they're less sensitive,
you know what I mean?
Cause the guys that make an aren't always the toughest of the biggest and the
strongest and the fastest.
It's the most emotionally tough.
So if you become a seal or you already predisposed to be less traumatized,
well there's a,
that's the case with a lot of fighters as well.
There's a lot of really physically talented guys that never make it.
They just,
they fall apart emotionally and they fall apart mentally and they can never,
they can never achieve greatness.
They get real fucking clothes.
And there's these guys that we would call Jim Legends were in the gym when
there's no stakes,
it's not difficult.
They fucking shine.
They look fantastic.
It's like people,
actors who are good at auditions.
Yeah.
Some are,
some aren't.
Some are good with this weird,
uh,
an authentic thing and they have to perfor I mean
comics who are hilarious in the parking lot bomb on stage.
Yes.
You think it.
Yes,
totally.
Do you think that it is a,
um,
level of Nar?
I mean,
I've been around,
you've been around more athletes and I have,
but um,
what,
I haven't dated a couple of athletes.
There's this disconnect,
this lack of empathy and I dare I say narcissism that I don't know if must work
for them in order to become an elite athlete.
I would imagine you'd have to have a healthy level of like narcissism and ego.
I think there's probably something in the,
I think ego and athletes,
like it goes so hand in hand,
especially with pro athletes,
it's so hand in hand that you gotta think,
man,
there's gotta be some sort of connection there.
Here's where it gets interesting.
Illusional on some level doing a lot of ways.
Yeah,
I'm invincible.
But here's where it gets interesting with fighters.
It's not the case.
The best fighters almost have like sort of a zen ability to block all that
bullshit out.
They have a belief in themselves,
but they have a zen ability to block all that shit out.
And that's why there was some of the most friendly people.
Some of the best fighters are some of the nicest people you got.
Like Anderson Silva is one of the fucking nicest guys you'll ever meet.
He's so friendly and sweet and he's always like hugging people and smiling and
laughing.
And he was a fucking murderer when he was the champ.
I mean,
he was one of the best ever.
Yeah.
Like I could go down the list of some of the best guys.
Frankie Edgar is one of the best w featherweights in the world.
Used to be lightweight,
like sweetheart fucking nicest guy.
He's so nice.
And he's a fucking assassin.
One gun
box or person from the,
I don't know anything about this field,
but,
um,
my ex had a boxing gym who had,
I think it was Canelo Canelo Alvarez and he doesn't watch horror movies or only
watches like will Ferrell,
like sweet,
like,
you know,
doesn't allow negativity in his brain at all because negativity breeds and
paranoia and
he doesn't even want to strengthen the part of your brain that even goes there.
No fucks with a lot of fighters.
Social media,
I can't even imagine.
I can't even imagine on these message boards and these people calling them
pussies and faggots and that work for or against,
you can use that as fuel or do you most of them against them.
Most of them against,
because their day,
they're dealing with their own fears constantly.
So they don't want more like what you are and who are you are in some ways
defined by what you believe and if you are insecure,
and then that insecurity gets reinforced by other people calling you a loser.
You know that guy fucking jokes.
I'm a chunker shit.
You know,
and then you get in there and you're like,
Fuck God,
a choker strengthen the neural pathway.
Like my,
I worked with this therapist,
she's like a trauma therapist and when I was going through a really bad breakup,
I was not allowed to talk.
What?
I swear you're going to like this,
you're not allowed to talk.
I was not allowed to mention the person for 90 days so that the,
we weaken the neural pathway of even thinking about the person.
So you're strengthening real.
Yeah.
You're strengthening neural pathways when you think like when you read tweets
about it and you're an idiot and whatever those ideas.
Yeah.
And then it's like the same way you quit coffee,
it takes 28 days to create a new habit.
Right.
Cause that's how long it takes to develop an our counseling.
I think it's 28 for a new neural pathway.
90 for,
I don't know.
You probably,
you probably know more about this than I do.
I think it depends on the habit.
Obviously.
We're both saying,
I think,
I think neither one of us fucking nowhere.
Someone Google it and hit us up.
Twitter,
I read someone's face bar,
call Neil degrasse Tyson backcheck or not,
but I know that 28 days is the minimum for Rehab because of that.
But 90 is really when it really matters.
Well,
it makes sense that there's pathways for sure,
because it's one of the hardest things for people to break his habits.
And that's also like one of the best ways to develop new creative thoughts is to
do new things.
Like take yourself completely out of your hundred percent out of your
environment,
out of your comfort zone.
That says,
when I'm trying to write something new,
I'll rearrange the furniture in my house because it just isn't great,
but it didn't knew like the couches in it.
It just gets your brain thinking outside of,
I like to go places.
Oh,
that's smart.
I go places and sometimes I would go places like,
I'll be in my car,
I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm a fucking drive somewhere I've never been before and just get out of my car.
Just go somewhere.
I think it's good to just be in a place that you,
you're not used to just like mix up your brain hall.
You get new perfume.
That sounds Dorky.
But like,
I know that sounds crazy,
but new smells,
new site,
new colors,
new everything.
So,
um,
uh,
I won't wear black when I write.
I know.
That's so stupid.
It might just be superstition.
I tried to work colors because it stimulates different parts of your brain,
different colors,
music,
smells,
candles.
If I'm starting a new script,
I'll have new candles.
Sage,
like stuff that just like stimulates.
You're bringing,
you know,
Benicio Del
Toro.
I'm interested.
I'm Mustang.
Oh No,
no,
sorry.
Yeah,
I was like,
I know that did seem very random.
Guillermo del Toro,
which is a fat,
ugly guy,
so don't,
don't have the same thoughts,
but he's very creative and he,
um,
was doing this thing where he took this,
uh,
these,
this camera crew minute tour of where he writes and his,
you know,
he's a horror writer.
Yeah.
So he,
his office is filled with like all these weird trinkets and objects and statues
and books and,
and all this cool shit.
And the reason being is that like he has designed this area,
this creative space to sort of stimulate his imagination.
Awesome.
What do you do when you sit down and write?
What's your process?
No,
we,
that's what I do.
I get rid of what I write.
So over to,
yeah,
but I,
I like to,
I like to write so high that I like feel like I have to get the words out before
they slip away.
Oh,
that's smart.
Well it's like what you do on stage when you dig a hole for yourself.
It's almost like sort of,
but it's obviously there's not as much pressure when you're riding,
but I feel like when I'm writing I like to get outside of my own comfort,
my own on my own control.
Like that's the thing that freaks people out most about pot is the paranoia.
What do you do?
Sativa or Nica?
I'll do both,
but I like sativa.
But do you do both?
Pick one for like hanging versus working.
You just,
I just like pot.
Yeah.
Okay.
We notice there's definitely a,
you investing in a weed thing.
There's something going on right now.
Talk to you about offstage,
offstage,
pyramid scheme.
No.
How dare you?
I'm joking.
Um,
I think it's probably a,
there's probably benefits to both to sativa and Indica.
Yeah.
Like indic is better for sex.
It's better for food.
It's better for relaxing.
Sativas I think probably a little bit better for creativity,
but sometimes it's not sometimes indicates great for us.
They're both good.
Yeah.
There's not that much of a difference in the effect is there's differences,
but both of them have very similar,
um,
creative enhancing effects,
at least to me.
Right.
I'm,
I'm convinced that everybody has a different reaction to it because I've
explained my reaction to marijuana to other people and they're like,
what?
Yeah.
You know,
and then you also have to be
to be as smart as you,
you know what I mean?
And creative and driven and et cetera.
I think alcohol too,
like I've talked to people that get like,
I know people that get angry and mean on alcohol.
Like they want to go out and get him to think that that's,
uh,
who they really are.
Maybe.
Do you think that like the truth comes out when your dream?
Maybe we could,
but I know people that drink in their fucking eyes turned like hamster eyes.
They're like gloss over there.
Like they're not even there anymore.
Something happened to me the day
I turned 30,
where I could not drink tequila anymore.
I was like,
the day I turned 30,
I was having like a dinner.
It was like a birthday or something.
And it was at Chateau Marmont.
Someone sent over,
um,
uh,
something like kind of new sent over a Tequila and he was like,
I bet you can't do shots to kill an icon.
Was it bill Cosby?
No day I woke up with my underwear or insulted that he didn't try to rape me.
But that's another story.
Um,
that same thing with crux dreammaker.
Everyone's like,
oh,
did you choose Georgia to hit on you?
I'm like,
no,
and now I feel bad and so sent over shots and I'm competitive,
so I was like,
I will crush you.
Wow.
Uh,
I woke up in my bed fully clothed,
looked at my phone,
80 miss text messages.
Did you go home with John Mayer?
And I was like,
I'm never drinking Tequila again.
Wow.
Yeah.
When you get it,
when you get a deed,
you go home with John Mayer.
Was it from a guy or girl?
It was from Oh,
tons of gun.
It was like,
it was a whole staff I was working with,
so it was like 30 people texting me.
You're not going home at John May or we're not going to let you go home.
What are you doing?
What's your cock block?
I know
that's a good plan.
I know you do anything for John Mayer.
Don't want to date me for two months.
Two months.
Spit me out.
It's been pretty good.
No,
spit on me.
Spit you at my whole entity out
there looking for mcfarlane,
Tiffany fun,
John Glenn,
Eco,
eco.
Who else?
The guy with the ponytail.
Rich girls from fear and loathing in Las Vegas?
No.
I want to get to a wolf man.
The recent one,
the one that,
no.
Is it good?
Really shitty movie in the background?
Sometimes when I write.
So you have movies that you have on the background.
When you write,
you have like specific go to movies,
sometimes
playing in the background music.
And then do you meditate before or after you write or during?
No,
no.
Sometimes I'm about to go in the tank
and then I decided to just start writing and I can't stop.
That's great.
That's fantastic.
I remember sometimes sometimes a bunch of bullshit.
You're like,
fucking how
send this to fucking carrot top.
I mean there are sometimes I'm just like,
I'm the worst person.
But that's how it is.
You're mining
the rock and occasionally find golden there.
And then something I think Johnny Carson said is that,
um,
be jokes that we would never do on stage that we write that or like be jokes
that don't deserve to be on stage set extemporaneously or a jokes.
So you just have this arsenal now of it.
But there's a Heckler,
like some joke that I wrote that never would make it to stage if I just do it
quote seemingly off the cuff,
it's all of a sudden in a joke.
There's definitely some there on a podcast or you're always going to,
you're going to use everything you write sometimes.
Yeah,
and then sometimes jokes are like seeds and they give birth to a new idea,
like maybe it'll be just a tag line or a new branch that you follow and that new
branch will be better than the original premise in the first place.
Yeah,
it's totally right.
I have,
since my first special,
I'm on my,
I just did my third and I was trying to write about squirting and the first one
couldn't get it,
didn't get it.
Second one couldn't get it,
couldn't figure it out.
The third one,
I have 25 minutes of squirting on special.
Outstanding.
Yes.
It's like the it hit it.
There was the right time.
It was like getting zeitgeisty in porn,
like I just had to wait for more to be revealed.
Ready?
It was premature.
The world is ready if you're
going to have to watch my special guys.
No,
they're,
my gynecologist says I'm not just being defensive because I can't do it.
Uh,
I mean I tried to do it myself and I peed all over myself.
Um,
I did,
I did it in my bathtub and I peed all over myself.
Someone had a good point.
I forget who it was,
but like,
how is it possible that that didn't exist until like a few years ago?
It's always,
exactly,
you know,
the women in porn use water balloons and stuff.
The ones that are like the end,
they pee the Bellagio fountain.
That is not real.
No,
none of it's real.
But you can at least 10% of it is always urine.
You're getting peed on it.
At least 10% is always urine.
You're getting paid on if you're into that.
Cool.
Um,
but yeah,
I,
there's,
I feel,
I don't like that there's a lot of these new sexual things that are,
make me feel bad.
Like I and guys watch so much porn and become so desensitized it all of a sudden
if I can't like squirt water across the room,
I'm like not good at fucking like why do I feel that?
Like I am awesome at this.
God Damn it,
why have you made me these Asian women are fucking killing Asian women are
squirting.
I feel like that's sort of where it started and that sort of,
you brought this up twice,
the Asian subservient thing,
right?
The ultimate like quiet.
So it's like you view yourself as being like this overbearing sort of force of
loud viking lady
just like Shrek,
anything you come on my asshole.
Yes.
Anything you want.
And so,
uh,
no,
I think that that a lot of guys,
it's just,
I'm obviously generalizing,
but a lot of guys in Hollywood just sort of like dated married Asian women and I
was like God damn,
I wish I was Asia.
Well some,
some women have real issues with that.
I mean this girl that I dated,
she fucking hated when men would break up with her and then start date an Asian
women.
Yeah.
Cause it's like,
okay,
I have a giant Pussy and I'm too loud.
That's what it makes you feel like.
It's like if someone broke up with you and then start dating a black guy,
you'd be like,
Oh fuck you got to deal with it.
Yeah.
And it's like,
you know,
but it's not to say that there aren't plenty of Sassy Asian woman with opinions,
but just the cliche is a cliche though,
the subservient
cliche,
the mail order bride,
but I know that so many guys that I know are like super into that.
Isn't it funny that like fan mail order bride is like serious pejorative,
right?
That's like the Russian mail order bride is dangerous.
Really?
I think so.
Yes.
For me,
once we'll just intense environment they grow up as in general are pretty
fucking teacher but like the mail order bride things like,
like the idea behind it is like negative.
Like oh you had to go search for mere Luther Bro.
I feel like if there was mail order husband,
I would have done it five years ago.
Really?
All my problems.
I'm quite fine.
Thank you.
I'm going to work.
It's a.net.
It's,
you know what it is?
It's like a Chippendale's dancer.
After a while you're gonna find out he's gay.
Yeah.
I think [inaudible] great.
I would love to date again.
Do you know shame?
Atosh Shayma has had two ex husbands.
It turned out to be gay.
Her latest one turned out to be gay,
too gay for pay to hold.
She's Hilarious when she tells the story.
She's like,
what the fuck am I attracting doing this guy that I'm pretty shy that everyone
told me was gay.
I didn't really care that much until,
until I taste,
but he was actually very sexual.
I don't know.
It's a very fluid time guys.
Yes it is.
Gender.
Gender is fluid.
Some tips of genders,
fluid,
fluid.
I mean there's a lot of MMA guys who are into that.
From what I understand,
I think a lot of fighters,
and I want to just say MMA guys,
some of them who have been abused,
they come from abusive households and sometimes that abuse could be sexual abuse
and it could be sexual abuse obviously by men.
And that could lead to a lot of confusion.
Sexual confusion.
I would think so.
Yeah.
Well there's also like I talked to this Guy Chris Ryan,
Dr Chris Ryan who were wrote this size,
good friend of mine,
he wrote this book sex at dawn and he's like an expert on sex.
And one of the things he was talking about is imprinting that sometimes when
something happens to you at a very early age,
even if you're not gay,
those sexual thoughts getting printed.
And there's something called [inaudible],
which was explained to me by the,
uh,
Chad Pres Mac.
Do you know him?
He's the neurologist guy for the Broncos.
You would love him.
He was explaining this thing called Texas,
which is when something traumatic happens,
but you're,
so if you're being jerking off let's say,
and something horrible happens,
you have a positive association with it.
So it was jerking off.
You just have to wash the twin towers.
What are you doing in there,
Mike [inaudible] stream
back to like old black and white footage just to feel totally.
So if you have some sort of thing and you're used to eating as a child to deal
with trauma and something that's happening and then you're releasing dopamine in
your brain and it's associated with something negative.
So that's a big one.
That eating one is a thing going with people that have a
trauma and they may see themselves with the food or it's Insta dove mean.
It's the fastest kind.
You don't have to go get to a drug dealer.
You don't have to fuck someone,
you don't have to get a hooker.
It's the most socially acceptable form of of dopamine and you don't have to deal
with people while you're doing it.
You can shut the door car jack in the box,
going to grocery stores like I hadn't done a why.
I'll be just because I was working and someone was going to grocery store for
me.
And recently I'm like,
I'm going to go to the grocery store myself,
I'm going to be a human being and I'm a comedian and we don't go to the grocery
store.
I do.
I do not.
Like when I was doing a couple things working in at a time,
I know it just didn't last a year.
I started going again.
Why do you go to the grocery store?
I never have.
Not really my whole life.
You've never had like,
do you have like a,
someone that manages your house?
No,
such a bad as I remember when I was like wanting to do this documentary I was
doing with my ex boyfriend and then I was like,
why am I doing working with my ex,
uh,
the state of play documentary,
which they're still doing,
um,
on Calseia Storico and fear and all that.
Um,
but uh,
I'm just not like running point on it.
Uh,
why do I bring that up?
Oh.
And I said to you,
I was like,
hey,
so can I have like HBO?
Like call like your assistant and you're like,
I don't have an assistant.
I do everything myself.
And it was just like,
that's so fucking bad ass.
What's normal?
That's like a person.
Yeah.
I think when I get to a point where I need an assistant,
I should back off.
Interesting.
I guess I overextend myself too much and my luxury is help.
I don't buy expensive shoes.
I don't the,
you know,
having a super nice,
I just,
uh,
help is when I,
and I don't mean that,
that sounds so like,
oh no slave owners.
Employees.
Yeah.
Or just like an assistant who helps me,
makes my doctor's appointments and just what does my schedule,
well,
I've see people that have like a whole industry behind them.
Like all these people and the handlers too much,
too much body guards.
He take with him on the road and they blink,
bring personal trainer everywhere.
And like,
there's too much input.
There's too much and you're being infantilized like in a way,
but in what you know,
you're sorta,
it's,
you were enabling more productivity because you're sort of,
you know,
you're sort of forming out all this,
these tasks.
But I feel like for me personally,
like I,
I value alone time and I value thinking and the almost,
the only way to do that is to not have obligations.
Like you have to have less,
less people that you have to communicate with more people,
you have to call back.
I think for me,
like I,
it's,
I'm so easily distracted and so,
uh,
perfection of my perfectionism,
perfectionism begets procrastination,
which begets paralysis.
So if I need,
if I to go to the grocery store,
it's going to take me three hours if I'm going and this,
and what about this?
And this has gluten and a bit of that,
like if someone else goes,
it takes an hour.
If I go,
it's like,
and then I'm in this and then I'm getting good lavender oil and then this
fucking Salt Himalayan salt,
second light,
I put on the,
and listen
to a podcast.
I put my phone in my pocket.
I pushed a cart around and smile at people and throw the vegetables in my cart.
I have a good old time.
So fucking hot.
I everything's hot.
Tea.
You need to get laid.
I dare you.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
I gotta I gotta go take my kids somewhere.
We're at a quarter to five now.
We're going to wrap this up.
We've got to do this more often and can we do this more often?
Let's do it and wait and see what each,
I love you too.
When's your HBO special coming out on January 23rd January 23rd and what's it
called?
I'm your girlfriend.
Oh,
right.
Powerful.
Whitney Cummings.
Everybody's powerful.
Powerful,
powerful audience.
Thank you everybody.
Love you guys.
Take care.
Bye.
Big Kiss.